Caption: well it boasted lower fees and faster
Caption: transactional times
Caption: and the interesting thing about ethereum
Caption: is it could track blocks of data not
Caption: just the ethereum coin
Caption: and these blocks of data can be used to
Caption: store programs often
Caption: you know little bits of code whatever
Caption: whatever you can think of and vitalik
Caption: had a vision you know he envisioned a
Caption: future where the whole internet was
Caption: rewritten where it was all decentralized
Caption: bypassing governments and banks and
Caption: other centralized services you know your
Caption: very identity could be stored on the
Caption: chain um a term that comes up a lot and
Caption: we're going to talk about it is banking
Caption: the unbanked and the forgotten
Caption: which personally i'm not too sure what
Caption: that actually means but we'll talk about
Caption: it okay so i've shared this quote from
Caption: it's doing that sorry i do apologize
Caption: it's doing that thing where it's like
Caption: skipping
Caption: slides
Caption: okay so i've shared this quote from
Caption: vitalik so i'll read it to you i cried
Caption: myself to sleep and on that day i
Caption: realized what horrors centralized
Caption: services can bring now that sounds
Caption: pretty drastic right so you'd think he'd
Caption: be talking about something
Caption: absolutely
Caption: devastating but it turns out he's
Caption: talking about world of warcraft so he
Caption: used to play world of warcraft
Caption: and he logs on one day to find that his
Caption: favorite mage wizard character's
Caption: favorite spell has been nerfed by the
Caption: dev team because the dev team thought it
Caption: was too effective
Caption: and that was his reaction and i haven't
Caption: posted this to make fun of him like
Caption: we've all got way attached to something
Caption: in our lives i've definitely got
Caption: attached to video games in the past
Caption: but it's just i think it's worth sharing
Caption: because it's interesting looking at the
Caption: sort of thought process that's happening
Caption: inside the head of a lot of the people
Caption: working in the web 3 space
Caption: okay so nfts i'm pretty sure you've all
Caption: seen nfts over the last few years they
Caption: really exploded during covid
Caption: or non-fungible tokens is their full
Caption: name it's a way of proving that
Caption: something is unique from a technical
Caption: perspective they're just a serial number
Caption: that can't be split into smaller parts
Caption: right so you know if you have two nfts
Caption: of the same thing they're gonna have
Caption: different serial numbers so if you took
Caption: a picture of me right now waving my arms
Caption: and we turn that into an nft the first
Caption: one would have one serial number the
Caption: second one would have another serial
Caption: number and it's a bit like prince of a
Caption: painting so you know when you have a
Caption: painting you make prints the first one
Caption: is worth the most the second one a
Caption: little bit less and third and so on and
Caption: so forth
Caption: now
Caption: nfts
Caption: often referred to as tokens that
Caption: digitalize something
Caption: can also store small packets of data or
Caption: code and these are often referred to as
Caption: smart contracts now nfts are supposed to
Caption: be a revolution where they could
Caption: liberate artists from the gig economy
Caption: they could be used for identity tickets
Caption: ownership and more
Caption: and i'm just going to once again just
Caption: step out of our little timeline here to
Caption: talk about another tweet from someone in
Caption: the nft space which i just
Caption: find a little confusing so nfts equal
Caption: identity 2.0
Caption: can't remember the last time i used my
Caption: picture on the left
Caption: and i'll read these out to you emphasis
Caption: on physical traits genetic lottery prone
Caption: to bias and prejudice and then under his
Caption: nft identity by choice unique and
Caption: digitally scarce representation of
Caption: values and beliefs now i'm going to put
Caption: aside the fact that the nft
Caption: looks like something that we used to
Caption: make in ms payne at high school
Caption: and the thing is santiago has a vested
Caption: interest in you believing this is the
Caption: case because he paid the equivalent of
Caption: 171
Caption: 000 u.s dollars for that nft
Caption: on the right
Caption: so quite interesting
Caption: okay so last technical term and then
Caption: we're going to delve into the
Caption: um the juicy bits um so web3 so web one
Caption: is like static content you know the web
Caption: in the early days where you would read
Caption: stuff you know on the internet you
Caption: didn't interact with it web 2 is users
Caption: creating content so like youtube social
Caption: media we make videos we make posts you
Caption: know it's a much more service orientated
Caption: internet web 3 is supposed to be this
Caption: new revolution in the crypto space where
Caption: users control their data and content
Caption: things are more distributed and it's not
Caption: controlled by big corporations now the
Caption: thing is i actually agree with some of
Caption: that you know terminology being used
Caption: there i do believe we should all control
Caption: our own data and i also believe that
Caption: having all the power in a few tech
Caption: companies is a bad idea
Caption: but i really disagree with the execution
Caption: okay so
Caption: time to spread some fud what's fud alex
Caption: um so in the crypto space when you
Caption: spread
Caption: negative thoughts or sentiment or point
Caption: out critical issues in a project you
Caption: often get accused of spreading fud you
Caption: know you're preventing us all going to
Caption: the moon and buying lambos or whatever
Caption: they say so let's spread some fun
Caption: okay let's talk about ransomware really
Caption: quickly ransomware is a terrible thing
Caption: right we are seeing schools hospitals
Caption: energy supply pipelines being held to
Caption: ransom by cyber criminals and most of
Caption: the time they have to pay in bitcoin to
Caption: get their data back once it's been
Caption: stolen and encrypted we even have
Caption: individuals i mean i'm sure there's some
Caption: of you in this room with grandparents
Caption: that have had their data stolen and been
Caption: you know held at ransom it happens all
Caption: the time
Caption: and this is a 5.2 billion dollar a year
Caption: industry that is insane in fact that
Caption: number has probably gone up since i made
Caption: this slide
Caption: and it's worth pointing out that this
Caption: industry is only as big as it is
Caption: because of things like bitcoin
Caption: because the thing is if you get held to
Caption: ransom with your data
Caption: and they say transfer twenty thousand
Caption: dollars to us please if you go down to
Caption: your bank to do that online or in person
Caption: they're going to have questions about
Caption: transferring twenty thousand dollars
Caption: they're not going to just let you do it
Caption: and the thing is if they know that the
Caption: receiver is a known criminal or on their
Caption: sanctions list they're also not going to
Caption: do it the thing is by creating things
Caption: like bitcoin we've actually created
Caption: loopholes around our centralized
Caption: services allowing industries like this
Caption: to flourish now look i'm not going to be
Caption: the first one to defend banks they have
Caption: screwed us over a lot you know just look
Caption: at 2008 for example but the thing is
Caption: centralized services exists for a reason
Caption: you know security sanctions and laws
Caption: need to be paid attention to and look
Caption: they're not always perfect but the thing
Caption: is we do have democratic governments so
Caption: we can try and get people elected that
Caption: make it better rather than creating
Caption: loopholes that create industries as
Caption: predatory as this
Caption: so let's talk about energy and
Caption: environment possibly my favorite topic
Caption: because i work in the climate space now
Caption: we're going to talk about bitcoin first
Caption: and for those of you who work in the
Caption: space don't worry we'll get to
Caption: environmentally friendly crypto coins as
Caption: well but we need to talk about bitcoin
Caption: because it is the biggest and the worst
Caption: right so bitcoin uses 0.5 percent of the
Caption: world's power just for bitcoin that is a
Caption: tremendous amount of energy it uses more
Caption: energy annually than argentina
Caption: and then the second factor that i think
Caption: is really really important it produces
Caption: more e-waste than the netherlands
Caption: right so bitcoin is responsible for
Caption: uh supply shortages in chips ssds and
Caption: more right so when the ps5 came out and
Caption: you couldn't get one i mean obviously
Caption: covet played a part but it was also due
Caption: to bitcoin miners using all these chips
Caption: that's why people couldn't get a ps5 and
Caption: you know personally i don't want to live
Caption: in a world where you can't get a
Caption: playstation 5 when you want one
Caption: and there's something else to be said
Caption: now i'm not going to debate this climate
Caption: change is real if you don't believe this
Caption: then you can ignore this part of the
Caption: talk but we have to transition to
Caption: renewable energy in australia i mean in
Caption: other countries they may have to use
Caption: nuclear but in other parts of the world
Caption: we've all got to transition right we
Caption: have to do it and there is only so much
Caption: energy in the world and one of my
Caption: arguments here is you really can't
Caption: afford to waste energy on a speculative
Caption: system like bitcoin when we have to
Caption: transition to save our future
Caption: and it's also worth noting that only a
Caption: few days ago just as i was doing another
Caption: practice the white house tweeted that
Caption: they are actually looking at
Caption: proof-of-work blockchains and
Caption: considering banning them because they're
Caption: going to prevent them from reaching
Caption: reaching their environmental targets
Caption: and bitcoin is really bad so many
Caption: dormant or near dormant fossil fuel
Caption: fired power plants are restarted to mine
Caption: bitcoin a power plant in new york
Caption: increased its emissions by six percent
Caption: and heated up a local lake when they
Caption: started mining bitcoin and we're seeing
Caption: this all the time there's so much green
Caption: washing going on we've got fossil fuel
Caption: companies bringing in big rigs of
Caption: bitcoin
Caption: miners and attaching it to gas burn off
Caption: to power it we're making fossil fuel
Caption: companies more profitable
Caption: so you know inevitably people can be
Caption: like alex
Caption: you keep talking about bitcoin which
Caption: uses proof of work which remember is
Caption: that complicated algorithm process to
Caption: add a block to a chain
Caption: now there are environmentally friendly
Caption: crypto cryptocurrencies as well and they
Caption: tend to use something called
Caption: proof-of-stake so it's more efficient
Caption: because it doesn't scale in cost and
Caption: time like proof-of-work but it does make
Caption: participation expensive so basically
Caption: validation is
Caption: achieved by how much a user has to stake
Caption: so for example you need to hold a
Caption: certain amount of the crypto or tokens
Caption: to be able to add blocks to the chain
Caption: so that makes it really easy for someone
Caption: with a lot of money to own the entire
Caption: chain which begs the question is it
Caption: really decentralized then
Caption: um so it's not as secure as proof of
Caption: work now ethereum currently uses proof
Caption: of work and is apparently going to be
Caption: switching to proof of stake for the last
Caption: seven years but they haven't however
Caption: they've made a big announcement this
Caption: month that they're finally going to do
Caption: it and it looks like they might actually
Caption: do it this time and that would make
Caption: ethereum environmentally friendly
Caption: however
Caption: that's not where my beef ends
Caption: so let's talk about fraud and scams now
Caption: one about to talk to you is all facts
Caption: and is a serious problem
Caption: 10.68 billion dollars has been lost to
Caption: scams or griffs since february 2021
Caption: this is out of date i made this slide
Caption: two weeks ago it has gone up
Caption: since then so let's have a look at the
Caption: scams that happen so rug pools these are
Caption: really common so it's where a developer
Caption: uh or you know a company raises
Caption: tokens and then makes a run for the door
Caption: with investments right so a good way to
Caption: think about this you know a startup you
Caption: have an idea you build an mvp you raise
Caption: investment you build the product you
Caption: grow the value of the company well in
Caption: the web 3 space what happens a lot of
Caption: the time is that you know people have
Caption: vague plans for a video game or a
Caption: product or something and then they raise
Caption: all these tokens
Caption: and then they just cash out and
Caption: disappear and they shut down all the
Caption: social media sites they shut down the
Caption: website i mean this one this one's
Caption: fantastic air moon rogue pools for 6.3
Caption: million dollars i mean besides being a
Caption: blatant pokemon riff off like
Caption: it's just or or my favorite one martin
Caption: the wonderful pharmaceutical guy from
Caption: america who jacked up the price of a
Caption: much needed drug once he got out of
Caption: prison he started his own nft project
Caption: and got hacked and all the money
Caption: disappeared very interesting
Caption: or this one bribe protocol team
Caption: disappears after raising 5.5 million
Caption: dollars i mean one the amount of money
Caption: that they raise is insane but the fact
Caption: that they just disappear and
Caption: most of the time get away with it is
Caption: really bad
Caption: now let's talk about lies because this
Caption: happens a lot and i think it's really
Caption: worth addressing
Caption: so celsius network is like a bank
Caption: savings account except the idea is you
Caption: put your crypto in it so if i have some
Caption: bitcoin or ethereum i can lend it to
Caption: celsius in like their account and they
Caption: loan it out to other people and i earn
Caption: interest on my crypto being with them
Caption: now it was touted as being safer than a
Caption: bank you know the new type of
Caption: investments but in the crypto crash this
Caption: year they suspended all withdrawals and
Caption: swaps in june and then in july they
Caption: filed for bankruptcy
Caption: now they've been accused of being a
Caption: ponzi scheme but during their bankruptcy
Caption: hearings people have written in to
Caption: explain the losses that they've suffered
Caption: now i've stayed up late at night reading
Caption: some of these and they are
Caption: brutal right they are absolutely
Caption: devastating some of them talk about
Caption: suicide and really dark things now i've
Caption: filtered out some of the darkest ones
Caption: but i've included three that i want to
Caption: read to you because i feel it's
Caption: important to understand the position
Caption: so my name is brandon lawrence i'm
Caption: writing the letter for the same reason
Caption: as many i am one of the little guys
Caption: i put my life savings and trust into
Caption: celsius and co even worse i took out a
Caption: margin loan on robin hood for 50 grand
Caption: for a bitcoin and it's near high and i
Caption: sent it to celsius to offset the monthly
Caption: margin interest
Caption: i also sent a bitcoin from when i was
Caption: buying a little bit here and there
Caption: around 2018 and up it was my nest egg
Caption: now when i go to work i drink water eat
Caption: any scraps i can find for lunch every
Caption: day i'm still paying for the bitcoin i
Caption: do not have with interest
Caption: i'm in deep depression and do not know
Caption: if i can pull myself out of this
Caption: here's another one for you both my wife
Caption: and i are depositors in celsius and have
Caption: three young boys age 11 17 and 20. we
Caption: are unaccredited usa investors and were
Caption: lured into celsius based on promises
Caption: directly from the ceo that our deposits
Caption: are safe and can be withdrawn at any
Caption: time the ceo of celsius stated several
Caption: times that celsius is safer and better
Caption: than a bank and those sentiments were
Caption: reflected in their advertising
Caption: now there is one more and just to give
Caption: you a warning there is a mention of
Caption: domestic violence uh just to let you
Caption: know
Caption: um just for any of those who might be
Caption: triggered by past experiences
Caption: during my life i've escaped domestic
Caption: abuse perpetrated within a 28 year
Caption: marriage raised an orphan as an older
Caption: adult without any support i've survived
Caption: a brain tumor while coping with
Caption: polycystic kidney disease debilitating
Caption: arthritis and extreme fibromyalgia
Caption: during the years of raising my son as a
Caption: single mother i scrimped and saved for a
Caption: meagre retirement regretfully i placed
Caption: 70 of my funds in an earned account in
Caption: the celsius network
Caption: now as a single senior citizen i faced
Caption: kidney dialysis additionally i'll be
Caption: forced to sell my home return to work
Caption: and possibly rely on government relief
Caption: to make up for this deception
Caption: now i know that some of you in this room
Caption: will be thinking hey you should only
Caption: invest what you can afford to lose
Caption: and i think it's really really important
Caption: to hear to point out that is victim
Caption: blaming celsius lied to these people
Caption: they defrauded them they sold them false
Caption: promises they told them things were safe
Caption: and their money was in good hands they
Caption: were lied to
Caption: so if this pops into your head please
Caption: just throw it away because it's an
Caption: invalid argument it is victim blaming
Caption: and i think another thing to think about
Caption: here is we live in a society which isn't
Caption: fair there are systems that when you end
Caption: up in poverty keep you down and the
Caption: chances are most of you in this room
Caption: might never have experienced poverty we
Caption: work in tech which gives us access to a
Caption: relatively good lifestyle but the thing
Caption: is when you're in poverty all you can do
Caption: is think about how am i going to get out
Caption: this where's my next meal going to come
Caption: from and when someone comes along
Caption: promising the world and saying to you
Caption: i've got the solution that's going to
Caption: break you out of the system that's going
Caption: to stop you from being poor you're going
Caption: to take that because you're looking for
Caption: that ray of hope
Caption: so i really hate this whole sentiment
Caption: that you should only invest what you can
Caption: afford to lose especially when the
Caption: companies selling the future are lying
Caption: so yeah look there's more scams inside
Caption: of trading uh so staff at coinbase have
Caption: been accused of buying tokens before
Caption: they list so coinbase is a platform
Caption: where you can buy and sell
Caption: cryptocurrency uh ponzi schemes endless
Caption: projects returning profits from new
Caption: investors to old investors wash trading
Caption: so that's kind of like where multiple
Caption: accounts all by the same or multiple
Caption: people sell nfts between them to inflate
Caption: the price by the way all of this stuff
Caption: that i've just mentioned
Caption: with normal security so like stocks and
Caption: bonds and companies it's against the law
Caption: if you do insider trading wash trading
Caption: you go to jail there is a whole
Caption: regulation industry set up to prevent it
Caption: and look it doesn't always work but it's
Caption: illegal and the thing is this industry
Caption: doesn't have any laws to protect it to
Caption: protect normal everyday people now we
Caption: are starting to see some punishments
Caption: in america and other places but so many
Caption: people are still getting away with all
Caption: these terrible things we also have
Caption: copyright issues artists who were
Caption: supposed to be liberated by nfts getting
Caption: angry when their work is stolen and
Caption: minted and sold as an nft without their
Caption: permission and i think my favorite part
Caption: about this is when they go to complain
Caption: they get laughed at or chastised saying
Caption: it's their fault for not doing it sooner
Caption: and being part of the future
Caption: you know theft because in crypto you
Caption: know we're not using banks you're
Caption: supposed to be your own bank it's so
Caption: easy to scam and fraud people dropping
Caption: nfts into people's wallets that when
Caption: they click it drains out all their money
Caption: now i could really go on about all these
Caption: but one i'll be having a classic
Caption: alexander rant and two it does get quite
Caption: depressing but i think it's worth
Caption: mentioning here that crypto is zero sum
Caption: by design now what does that even mean
Caption: um i have to admit when someone first
Caption: explained it to me i was like what
Caption: um but the best way to think about like
Caption: this when you buy a stock in a company
Caption: the company generates value because it
Caption: sells a service or it develops a product
Caption: so more people become interested in it
Caption: more people buy it so the value grows
Caption: right so you get value because it's
Caption: generated value in crypto that's not how
Caption: it works right blockchain doesn't and
Caption: bitcoin don't generate value not making
Caption: anything so your only chance to make
Caption: money is to buy low sell high but
Caption: because it isn't generating value when
Caption: you sell at a high than when you brought
Caption: you need someone else to put money in
Caption: for you to get out which means it's zero
Caption: sum because for you to take money out
Caption: someone has to put money in but when you
Caption: take into consideration minors and
Caption: exchanges that extract money from the
Caption: system it makes it strictly negative
Caption: some which is really weird because we
Caption: now have this system where we've got all
Caption: these fraud and scams it's zero sum by
Caption: design it almost sounds like a
Caption: multi-level marketing scheme and this
Caption: kind of gets backed up by these
Caption: wonderful celebrities here
Caption: doing all these wonderful crypto ads for
Caption: those of you who've not seen it matt
Caption: damon's ad where he compares investing
Caption: in crypto to landing on the moon and
Caption: basically causes all cowards for not
Caption: investing has to be the worst advert
Caption: i've ever seen
Caption: or the larry super bowl ad don't be like
Caption: larry start investing today or paris
Caption: hilton on late night talking about their
Caption: nfts because this is the thing it
Caption: doesn't generate value so to keep money
Caption: coming in they have to keep the hype
Caption: train going otherwise it stops
Caption: so let's explore this decentralized
Caption: things we're going to shift lanes a
Caption: little bit here so we've talked about
Caption: the ford and scams and things but let's
Caption: talk about decentralized so that's
Caption: that's one of the big touts that's
Caption: decentralized we own it it's not owned
Caption: by people
Caption: but most of the major services in the
Caption: web3 space are run on centralized
Caption: servers and just query the blockchain
Caption: with an api if a miner owns 51 of a
Caption: network is it really decentralized
Caption: and these are things that all worth
Caption: thinking if you have to have a bank
Caption: account and go through a centralized
Caption: exchange to use a web3 app
Caption: is it decentralized i have to admit i
Caption: set up a metamask wallet myself and it
Caption: took me about half an hour and i'm a
Caption: developer so god knows how we're going
Caption: to get normal people to do it
Caption: so i think moxie here sort of helps me
Caption: with my decentralized argument so moxie
Caption: is one of the founders of signals so he
Caption: created this nft um if you want to go
Caption: figure out how he did it it's up on his
Caption: twitter but basically it looked
Caption: different based on where you viewed it
Caption: so if you viewed it on openc one of the
Caption: biggest centralized platforms for buying
Caption: and selling nfts it looked one way and
Caption: if you looked at it on variable another
Caption: but if you looked at it in your crypto
Caption: wallet it rendered out as a poo emoji
Caption: which is just
Caption: absolutely fantastic
Caption: but this is funny he was delisted from
Caption: open c for violating their terms and
Caption: conditions but i thought it was a
Caption: censorship-free decentralized system
Caption: but it gets even better then his crypto
Caption: wallet stopped showing the nft because
Caption: it turns out his crypto wallet just
Caption: queried open c's api to check for the
Caption: nft's existence so
Caption: none of that is decentralized that's all
Caption: using centralized
Caption: services
Caption: so let's dig into censorship resistance
Caption: a little bit now i want to start by
Caption: saying
Caption: i am a firm believer
Caption: in freedom of speech you have the right
Caption: to say whatever you want and i think
Caption: that should be right and it's very
Caption: depressing in other countries where
Caption: governments use their power to suppress
Caption: that but the thing is freedom of speech
Caption: does not give you freedom of
Caption: consequences and also using your freedom
Caption: of speech to suppress other people's
Caption: freedom of speech is plain wrong
Caption: and i think we need to talk about this
Caption: censorship resistant blockchain because
Caption: the thing is there is stuff out there
Caption: that needs censoring right since content
Caption: moderators that work for youtube
Caption: facebook and twitter they don't last
Caption: very long in their jobs censoring the
Caption: content that gets uploaded and they see
Caption: the worst of humanity there are some
Caption: dark places in our society child porn
Caption: animal violence this stuff is real and
Caption: it happens all the time and needs to be
Caption: censored if we create a censorship
Caption: resistant complete system we are going
Caption: to allow child pornography hate racism
Caption: to just spew out all online which isn't
Caption: really a great place
Caption: and let's expand on that a little bit
Caption: and talk about the death of privacy so
Caption: i'm a big privacy advocate i go out of
Caption: my way at the start up i work at to try
Caption: and respect privacy as much as possible
Caption: even building analytics in a different
Caption: way all that sort of stuff
Caption: and privacy is important and blockchain
Caption: often gets touted as it's more secure
Caption: it's the data in your hands and look we
Caption: should have data in our hands i agree
Caption: with that
Caption: but the thing is it's not really private
Caption: because i cannot stress this enough it's
Caption: a public ledger everything you do is
Caption: visible to the public now if you don't
Caption: connect that identity to anything in the
Caption: real world sure it gives you the ability
Caption: to harass and annoy and disappear right
Caption: but the second you start connecting it
Caption: to anything in the real world or someone
Caption: figures out that that wallet belongs to
Caption: you everything you do is going to be
Caption: available for everyone to see we're
Caption: talking privacy violations
Caption: way worse than google and facebook have
Caption: ever committed
Caption: especially when you've got things like
Caption: this
Caption: ethereum co-founder says we'll soon use
Caption: soul bound tokens to verify things like
Caption: school and employment all stored in a
Caption: soul's wallet i don't even know what any
Caption: of that means
Caption: but the thing is once we start attaching
Caption: things like that to the blockchain
Caption: that's there forever because remember it
Caption: can't be deleted
Caption: even if it's fought it can still be
Caption: found you know accidentally take a photo
Caption: with your credit card in the background
Caption: that's up there forever somebody uploads
Caption: revenge point of view that's up there
Caption: forever it's never going away and i
Caption: think there's another thing worth
Caption: mentioning is that most of the people
Caption: working in this space are straight white
Caption: men like me and we don't experience
Caption: harassment
Caption: stalking in the same way that people of
Caption: color or women do we just don't
Caption: and the thing is that stuff will become
Caption: easier to do
Caption: like i said privacy will disappear
Caption: so we're running short on time because
Caption: we start a little bit late so let's just
Caption: just cool off a little bit alex and
Caption: we'll go into financialization of
Caption: everything um so so one of the end goals
Caption: of the web 3 space right is that
Caption: everything is on the chain everything
Caption: you do is on the chamber incentivized
Caption: for our time with earning tokens
Caption: uh you pay for everything on the chain
Caption: and i think one real good example of
Caption: this is axi infinity uh which is a video
Caption: game using nfts and blockchains
Caption: it's pretty much just pokemon it's
Caption: pokemon with nfts
Caption: um so the way it works is you buy or
Caption: rent three nfts called axes
Caption: um and then you battle them and you earn
Caption: tokens for battling and you use those
Caption: tokens to breed more axes or you can
Caption: cash out for real
Caption: money
Caption: now it's very expensive to get started
Caption: like when it first started it was very
Caption: low it can be cost a few hundred dollars
Caption: at least to set up one team one thing
Caption: you can do is set up a bunch of teams
Caption: and rent them out to people and then you
Caption: earn 50 of whatever they're doing now
Caption: they've got a lot of good press
Caption: about how they help people in the
Caption: philippines earn money you know it's
Caption: like hey these people are now earning
Caption: money you know playing a video game but
Caption: the thing is play to earn is not play to
Caption: have fun so when we had the crypto crash
Caption: earlier this year they saw their player
Caption: numbers drop massively because people
Caption: were just using it to earn money they
Caption: were just grinding to earn money and
Caption: when you take into consideration there's
Caption: lots of whales so that's people with
Caption: lots of money renting out nfts earning
Caption: 50
Caption: of the money they're earning it almost
Caption: sounds a bit like a sweat factory but
Caption: let's let's let's investigate that
Caption: good press on how many people in the
Caption: philippines make money earning
Caption: you know earning playing the game only
Caption: 23 of adults in the philippines have a
Caption: bank account right so make remember you
Caption: need a bank account to buy crypto and
Caption: play crypto and work with crypto so how
Caption: many people are we actually helping i
Caption: feel that's one of the things that we do
Caption: in tech a lot it's like this solves this
Caption: problem we should do it but we never
Caption: actually talk to the people we say we're
Caption: helping you know and i think uh example
Caption: outside of the web three space you might
Caption: hate me for this and this is okay is
Caption: elon musk's satellite system for
Caption: internet right like he's like oh we're
Caption: bringing internet to people in the
Caption: regions have we asked them what they
Caption: want it's internet top of their list i'm
Caption: pretty sure that if you talk to most
Caption: people living in the regions they'd be
Caption: like uh 24-hour access to doctors and
Caption: nurses more public services and
Caption: infrastructure that isn't falling apart
Caption: and 50 years old you know not saying the
Caption: internet isn't important but it's one of
Caption: those things where like let's just shove
Caption: a whole bunch of satellites in the
Caption: atmosphere every year and not think
Caption: about the consequences because
Caption: apparently we're doing some good
Caption: and in the end it's people that lose
Caption: right like it's people that get left out
Caption: it's people that suffer the consequences
Caption: of us just charging ahead and doing
Caption: something i think not a week goes by
Caption: where people aren't like oh let's stick
Caption: this on the blockchain for example let's
Caption: put power distribution and on the
Caption: blockchain that will make things better
Caption: but then who decides when we disconnect
Caption: someone when they're struggling with
Caption: finances who decides that we keep
Caption: someone connected to the power because
Caption: they've got medical devices if we
Caption: create this decentralized system a
Caption: really good example is if you take
Caption: synergy or state-owned power company and
Caption: you compare that to all the private
Caption: companies over east which is a little
Caption: bit like a blockchain they all don't
Caption: really work together that well they all
Caption: do whatever they want our disconnection
Caption: rate
Caption: our disconnection rate in wa for people
Caption: in financial hardship is much lower
Caption: because we have a centralized system
Caption: working together
Caption: you know look at myspace the environment
Caption: space everyone's like oh if we put
Caption: offsets on the blockchain it fixes them
Caption: you know we need carbon offsets to
Caption: offset some emissions that are
Caption: unavoidable but the thing is the
Caption: industry is rife with lies fraud kicking
Caption: people off their own land in third world
Caption: countries and the thing is how does
Caption: sticking that on the blockchain fix it
Caption: one it doesn't stop people lying before
Caption: they put data in there and all it does
Caption: is create another financial market on
Caption: top of the other
Caption: and i think that's the biggest thing
Caption: that i want you guys to take away from
Caption: this is that tech alone isn't going to
Caption: save us we have to actually trust each
Caption: other and work together and stop just
Caption: pushing ahead with tech because it seems
Caption: cool of fun
Caption: so please just remember we can trust
Caption: each other we can work together and
Caption: centralized systems are important too
Caption: i'd like to thank some of these amazing
Caption: people that i got some of the content
Caption: for this talk from because i feel like
Caption: although i read and work in this space a
Caption: bit these people are far more
Caption: experienced than i am molly y in
Caption: particular
Caption: is probably the coolest person you could
Caption: ever meet and kicking ass and
Caption: documenting some of the terrible things
Caption: happening in this space
Caption: and i'd also like to thank our sponsors
Caption: for today at dd perth thank you very
Caption: much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you alex
Caption: we've got about five minutes before
Caption: there's morning tea in all the foyers
Caption: the next session is starting at 11 25 so
Caption: is there anyone who's got a question for
Caption: alex before we wrap up
Caption: oh dear
Caption: so the hype train's real
Caption: how do we get investors
Caption: in startups to avoid throwing cash at
Caption: shiny things that have web 3 and
Caption: crypto in them oh
Caption: see so that's a difficult question right
Caption: and i don't have a perfect answer for
Caption: that um because i work for a startup too
Caption: and i've seen other companies just come
Caption: along with a wild idea get millions of
Caption: dollars and
Caption: we only ever got a few hundred thousand
Caption: to start with so i think i think there's
Caption: that thing where it's like you have to
Caption: look at is endless growth always a good
Caption: thing can i bootstrap a startup with
Caption: income first before i go to investors
Caption: and just try and avoid those investors
Caption: which means less stuff will be built
Caption: that doesn't have web3 but hey maybe we
Caption: have a slightly better society for it as
Caption: well too
Caption: awesome answer any other questions
Caption: yeah just be curious in your
Caption: opinion on whether there exists maybe a
Caption: possibility for some sort of
Caption: decentralized financial product for
Caption: example i'm thinking of the problems on
Caption: the internet with a mastercard and visa
Caption: stranglehold
Caption: on certain services
Caption: yeah so i do have an answer for this and
Caption: some of you might not like it
Caption: so
Caption: i agree things like internet and payment
Caption: actually internet infrastructure not
Caption: just payment infrastructure is a
Caption: necessary for today's world right just
Caption: like electricity and water and necessity
Caption: so maybe it's time that certain
Caption: infrastructure
Caption: isn't actually owned by private
Caption: companies anymore but actually a public
Caption: owned good now look yeah governments
Caption: have some bad reputations for running
Caption: things but the thing is maybe that's
Caption: actually what starts to need to happen
Caption: maybe we need a publicly owned payment
Caption: infrastructure maybe we need publicly
Caption: owned infinite internet and server
Caption: infrastructure because the thing is we
Caption: actually need it to function and maybe
Caption: it's time we modernize our governments a
Caption: little bit to make that possible
Caption: thank you
Caption: fantastic any other questions
Caption: i was just gonna ask so
Caption: obviously in the late 90s we had the the
Caption: dot-com bubble where a bunch of
Caption: companies went on the internet and they
Caption: didn't have to and everything just kind
Caption: of went straight down downhill from
Caption: there yeah but obviously the underlying
Caption: technology was somewhat useful in the
Caption: modern world
Caption: so do you feel the whole system of web 3
Caption: as a whole is completely useless or is
Caption: it more that it's kind of the wild wild
Caption: rest right now i
Caption: personally i agree
Caption: that it is useless but that's my
Caption: personal opinion and i i disagree with
Caption: the wild wild west because although
Caption: there was a bit of while west when the
Caption: dot-com bubble happened there wasn't
Caption: this level of fraud and scams right
Caption: that's that's this is insane if this was
Caption: happening in the banking industry on a
Caption: daily basis it will be on the news every
Caption: night right like it's and and the thing
Caption: is look maybe there is a use for
Caption: blockchain that i'm not aware of right
Caption: that we could actually do but
Caption: technically don't we already have that
Caption: and i think it's called git you know
Caption: like it's uh
Caption: maybe we already found the use case um
Caption: look i just i just want people to be
Caption: protected so you know really i think the
Caption: industry should be regulated and i think
Caption: you'd find if that happened it would
Caption: probably mostly disappear because like i
Caption: said it's zero sum by design
Caption: awesome uh one last question over here
Caption: uh so you talked about uh public
Caption: ownership or government ownership is
Caption: there any initiatives like that
Caption: they've uh started or are they thinking
Caption: about it
Caption: no no there isn't uh which sucks right i
Caption: mean there are some people in america
Caption: talking about it
Caption: um but i think that's actually what
Caption: needs to happen right we need to stop
Caption: saying oh you know government's terrible
Caption: at running this well let's make a
Caption: government good at running this right i
Caption: know people push for privatization of
Caption: synergy and look we're delving into my
Caption: personal beliefs a little bit here but
Caption: that's okay
Caption: and you're allowed to disagree with me
Caption: but i believe our energy should be state
Caption: owned you know it kept our power prices
Caption: lower most of the time it leads to
Caption: better things this whole thing of choice
Caption: in certain things is important but when
Caption: it's infrastructure so really maybe
Caption: working in the tech space we should all
Caption: start pushing for that because it is
Caption: needed
Caption: awesome and uh can we give another round
Caption: of applause to alexander thank you thank
Caption: you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: he's going to be kidnapped briefly for a
Caption: photo of all uh speakers but after that
Caption: he will be in the foyer and i'm sure you
Caption: can track him down for any other
Caption: questions thank you for joining us
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: night
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: first
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: do
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: good
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: night
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together
Caption: now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths i am cassandra i am a
Caption: test automation especially
Caption: pink beret uh as you can tell by the
Caption: accent i am french very very prominent
Caption: accent
Caption: so the berry completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say i'm not
Caption: the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top line
Caption: of testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top run is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: hi
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: hi
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott handsome
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: [Music]
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: what do you want
Caption: [Music]
Caption: oh
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is
Caption: you need a professional bodyguard
Caption: delivered to your door in less than half
Caption: an hour you've got it buddy but without
Caption: an app ain't no bodyguard getting
Caption: delivered nowhere so where are we with
Caption: that uh the app is almost ready uh we
Caption: just need three
Caption: more days we needed asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up
Caption: steven we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all we have
Caption: james and james here to take us on a pen
Caption: testing adventure
Caption: we have one james who is from vgw and
Caption: the other from bankwest so i'm sure it's
Caption: going to be quite an interesting
Caption: session if we have time we'll have some
Caption: questions at the end so
Caption: feel free to formulate those through the
Caption: session without further ado james and
Caption: james
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: everyone i'm james number one for the
Caption: purposes of this talk so i work at
Caption: bankwest in the identity platform
Caption: um
Caption: in 2019 my friend convinced me to join
Caption: his team uh participating in wactf uh
Caption: it's a cyber security competition if
Caption: you're not aware of it
Caption: um
Caption: unfortunately our team kind of arrived a
Caption: bit late to the venue and instead of
Caption: being allowed in the room with the other
Caption: guests we got relegated to the foyer out
Caption: there
Caption: uh in spite of that we took fourth place
Caption: that year um and i kind of credit that
Caption: with i guess igniting a passion for
Caption: cyber security
Caption: um so
Caption: that's me i'll let james two introduce
Caption: himself now yes and i'm james number two
Caption: james number one just slightly cooler
Caption: i
Caption: my interest in cyber security began when
Caption: i was working at bankwest in the grad
Caption: program i spent six months working there
Caption: in the security operations centre
Caption: and the team there was super passionate
Caption: about security and that ended up rubbing
Caption: off on me a little bit from there i
Caption: started participating in things like
Caption: hack the box wactf much the same as
Caption: james
Caption: james and i met together when we were
Caption: working for six months at bankwest under
Caption: piers who's in the room
Caption: we've kept in touch ever since and james
Caption: suggested the idea of
Caption: doing a ddd talk together
Caption: i pitched the idea of doing a choose
Caption: your own pentest adventure because it's
Caption: something that i'm interested in and
Caption: that's the idea we ended up sticking
Caption: with
Caption: we also like to do gymnastics together
Caption: on the weekly
Caption: uh so the goals of the session
Caption: we've got four main goals that we'd like
Caption: the audience to take away from this
Caption: as long as you tick off at least one of
Caption: those i'll be satisfied uh we'd like to
Caption: give everyone here a little bit of a
Caption: peek at what breaking into
Caption: a website or a service looks like
Caption: certainly when i was working as a
Caption: software engineer i
Caption: very rarely got to see what that looks
Caption: like i knew that managing
Caption: vulnerabilities was important and
Caption: avoiding flaws that let people break in
Caption: was important but i never actually got
Caption: to see it practically applied
Caption: we'd also like to share with you all
Caption: some practical tips for the engineers in
Caption: the room hopefully whatever service or
Caption: application you're working on at the
Caption: moment won't be
Caption: vulnerable in the same way that our demo
Caption: website will be
Caption: we'd also like audience participation
Caption: we've formed this as a choose your own
Caption: adventure we want the audience to feel
Caption: empowered to actually make some of the
Caption: decisions that are going to drive this
Caption: live demo
Caption: so we're hoping to give you enough
Caption: context
Caption: that you
Caption: feel comfortable making a bit of a
Caption: decision and participating
Caption: which will hopefully lead to number four
Caption: which is giving you some inspiration
Caption: if anyone in the room is interested
Caption: definitely hit me up afterwards but
Caption: we'll also be sharing some resources at
Caption: the end for anyone who thinks this looks
Caption: cool and wants to do more of it to go
Caption: and do it on the in their own time after
Caption: this session so really hoping that some
Caption: of you take that away from this
Caption: so how's the adventure choose your own
Caption: adventure actually going to work we're
Caption: going to start off by doing a bit of
Caption: giving you a bit of context we'll um
Caption: browse around the website at whatever
Caption: point we're at
Caption: point out some interesting things that
Caption: we've spotted and then we'll go into
Caption: explaining some of the options that uh
Caption: that are available to us
Caption: from there you'll see a screen that
Caption: looks much like this one so have your
Caption: phones ready there's a qr code if you're
Caption: at the back it might struggle to scan
Caption: but we'll also read you out the six
Caption: digit number
Caption: so you can use one or the other you
Caption: either go to strawpol.live and enter the
Caption: six digit code or
Caption: you scan the qr code on your phone both
Caption: will take you to a
Caption: actual
Caption: straw poll where you can cast your votes
Caption: this one's not the real one so this is
Caption: just a demo one i see people think the
Caption: qr code won't work
Caption: all right
Caption: i'm gonna hop on the keyboard now and
Caption: james is gonna
Caption: narrate while i start exploring the
Caption: website
Caption: right so the app that we're going to be
Caption: pen testing is a an online pen store um
Caption: unfortunately because of some vpn issues
Caption: the thumbnails are not loading but um
Caption: these are various different pens that
Caption: you can browse through and add to your
Caption: cart there's also a search feature up
Caption: here you can type in a query and it'll
Caption: filter the list
Caption: to ones that match that query there's a
Caption: gallery here once again vpn issues so
Caption: the content is not loading
Caption: but imagine there's some beautiful pen
Caption: pictures here
Caption: finally we see a login page so we know
Caption: there's some kind of account system on
Caption: this website
Caption: we're going to register an account for
Caption: the purposes of this test
Caption: so there's obviously no password policy
Caption: because we're not getting any validation
Caption: errors so we've just put in test as a
Caption: password
Caption: we connected
Caption: all right i might swap across to the
Caption: video it looks like we're gonna have to
Caption: fall back on a pre-recorded video
Caption: because our vpn is uh acting up
Caption: obviously we've
Caption: we've registered our user we're logging
Caption: in now
Caption: yep so obviously a different user um
Caption: given that it's pre-recorded so once
Caption: you're in there's a profile page here um
Caption: and in that page you can update some of
Caption: your profile details so your name and
Caption: email address
Caption: and uh looking at the url we can see
Caption: this is hosted in s3 so that tells us
Caption: that it's a static website um so we're
Caption: gonna kind of browse through the
Caption: javascript code that's um we can see in
Caption: the dev tools and see if we can um find
Caption: anything interesting
Caption: so we're going to start noticing that
Caption: it's react um
Caption: and we're just going to try to enumerate
Caption: the routes that are available to see if
Caption: there's any pages that we haven't been
Caption: able to find yet um so we'll do that by
Caption: prettifying the code and then we're
Caption: going to search for a route that we know
Caption: exists in this case slash login
Caption: and we've immediately found a list of
Caption: all of the routes
Caption: so one that we
Caption: um haven't seen yet that's interesting
Caption: is this add product page
Caption: so we're just gonna go and navigate into
Caption: that and see if um there's anything
Caption: interesting there
Caption: all right so we get a forbidden error so
Caption: immediately that tells us we've got some
Caption: kind of role-based access control in
Caption: place
Caption: um so next order of business we're going
Caption: to try to enumerate the roles that exist
Caption: um so we're just going to search for
Caption: strings that tend to appear in role
Caption: names guest user admin and it looks like
Caption: we found a map of roles and it looks
Caption: like admin and user are the only two
Caption: roles that are defined
Caption: since we didn't have access to add
Caption: product page we can deduce that we're
Caption: probably just a normal user
Caption: but we're going to confirm that by
Caption: looking in local storage which is where
Caption: single page apps tend to put their
Caption: session data
Caption: and uh we can see here that there's a
Caption: role field and we are indeed a user
Caption: right so having seen that that gives us
Caption: our first goal which is going to be to
Caption: become the website admin
Caption: so
Caption: let's look at the options that are
Caption: available to do that
Caption: so the first option classic sql
Caption: injection
Caption: 12 hands if you've heard of it
Caption: yeah pretty much pretty much everyone um
Caption: so in our case we have this search
Caption: feature which is probably a good
Caption: candidate um so if our products are
Caption: stored in a sql database which is being
Caption: queried to uh produce the search results
Caption: um we can assume that our query might
Caption: end up embedded in a query like this
Caption: where it's filtering on rows that have a
Caption: description field containing our search
Caption: term uh now if the website is vulnerable
Caption: to sql injection
Caption: we would imagine that we could put in a
Caption: query that can escape this context and
Caption: do something more malicious with it
Caption: but there'll be more detail on that if
Caption: we choose that option
Caption: second option
Caption: is mass assignment
Caption: so
Caption: this one
Caption: relies on the fact that we know that
Caption: there's some kind of admin user we know
Caption: that we can register a basic user and
Caption: the question is can we upgrade our
Caption: existing user or register a new one as
Caption: an admin
Caption: so
Caption: um we can assume that there's some kind
Caption: of roll column stored in the user data
Caption: if there's an api endpoint that doesn't
Caption: enforce proper validation uh it may
Caption: allow us to overwrite some fields that
Caption: we're not supposed to by forcibly
Caption: providing extra input and thereby force
Caption: our user to become an admin
Caption: again more detail on that if we choose
Caption: it
Caption: finally brute forcing pretty simple if
Caption: we spam login attempts we might be able
Caption: to
Caption: ascertain the user the admins username
Caption: and password we don't know their
Caption: username but we can take some guesses at
Caption: it
Caption: um again we'll look at that in more
Caption: detail if that's what gets chosen
Caption: all right so you've seen all the options
Caption: now it's time to vote uh if you're at
Caption: the back and you're having trouble
Caption: reading that the url is strawpoll.live
Caption: and the pin number is 602 156
Caption: so um as soon as we get a clear result
Caption: on the poll we'll uh we'll call it and
Caption: we'll go down that path
Caption: and we won't be waiting for absolutely
Caption: everyone to vote unfortunately as soon
Caption: as we have a clear winner we'll go ahead
Caption: just in the interest of time
Caption: just trying to see if anyone's phones
Caption: are still up we'll go across we'll look
Caption: at the results
Caption: oh
Caption: no internet
Caption: minor problem
Caption: that explains the vpn issue
Caption: no wonder i needed to use the the video
Caption: back up
Caption: all right looks like yeah it looks like
Caption: mass assignment is a is a pretty clear
Caption: winner so uh let's go down that path um
Caption: all right i'll uh well hopefully while
Caption: that's reconnecting
Caption: it requires a password
Caption: all right
Caption: i'm just going to go ahead with the
Caption: video
Caption: all right so here we are
Caption: um
Caption: the page that catches our eye as far as
Caption: potential mass assignment vulnerability
Caption: is the profile page so we can update
Caption: some of the user's details
Caption: um so we're just going to turn on this
Caption: tool called burp suite
Caption: which is going to let us intercept
Caption: requests and actually see what's
Caption: happening behind the scenes when we do
Caption: this
Caption: right so just for a simple explanation
Caption: of how this works normally your browser
Caption: will send web requests directly to the
Caption: backend api um we're turning on a tool
Caption: called burp suite which kind of proxies
Caption: that
Caption: takes requests intercepts them allows
Caption: you to tamper with them or repeat them
Caption: and forwards them onto the api so
Caption: that'll just give us some means of kind
Caption: of messing with these requests and
Caption: seeing what we can do
Caption: right so ignore this first request
Caption: because you can see it's just an options
Caption: request just required um for calls to
Caption: work um this is the one that we're
Caption: interested in uh this is the one where
Caption: you can see all of the data that we
Caption: entered into the um
Caption: into the profile form has gone through
Caption: and we're just gonna send it to repeater
Caption: um which will let us kind of duplicate
Caption: this request later
Caption: and we can see in what comes back here
Caption: that we've got the complete uh set of
Caption: user claims including their role
Caption: but note that all we sent in that
Caption: request was just the details that we
Caption: were allowed to update
Caption: so now we're going to try to tamper with
Caption: this
Caption: in particular we're going to add a role
Caption: field and we're going to put admin in
Caption: there and we're just going to see if
Caption: that succeeds and what happens
Caption: we got a 200 response so uh
Caption: it succeeded in sending the request and
Caption: we can see that the role field says
Caption: admin now so that's a good indicator
Caption: that we've probably succeeded
Caption: um so the next thing we're going to do
Caption: is just log out and back in because this
Caption: website wasn't really designed
Caption: most likely for a user to change their
Caption: raw mid session so just to avoid any
Caption: inconsistencies
Caption: and make sure we refresh the session
Caption: state all right now that we're here we
Caption: can see immediately that we have a new
Caption: menu that we didn't have before and it
Caption: includes this ad product page which we
Caption: can now access
Caption: so we are now in
Caption: all right so time to reflect a little
Caption: bit on what the developer did right and
Caption: wrong here
Caption: um so what's actually happened is that
Caption: they've intended to
Caption: send these
Caption: details that are allowed to be updated
Caption: email first name and last name and
Caption: superimpose them on the existing user
Caption: record and store that in the database
Caption: when we included an extra field role
Caption: there was nothing in the api that
Caption: validated that and there was nothing
Caption: that stopped it from being superimposed
Caption: on top of the user record and being
Caption: stored so we just accepted it saved it
Caption: and we became an admin
Caption: right so what they should have done is
Caption: allow listed user input explicitly so
Caption: you only allow the fields that should be
Caption: updated by that endpoint in this case
Caption: email first name and surname
Caption: um another thing they could have done is
Caption: just to not use local accounts at all
Caption: it's very difficult to implement good
Caption: user account management there's a lot of
Caption: issues that kind of come into play using
Caption: a third-party service like
Caption: azure ad or cognito or auth0 something
Caption: like that will solve a lot of those
Caption: problems for you
Caption: um and also just a note on this um a
Caption: couple of popular javascript frameworks
Caption: are vulnerable to this out of the box so
Caption: nest js and um fastify both will by
Caption: default not validate input fields and
Caption: we'll just kind of deserialize whatever
Caption: you send it and
Caption: if you don't check for that explicitly
Caption: they will save it
Caption: all right so now james is going to hop
Caption: on the keyboard i've tethered so
Caption: hopefully we've got internet if i just
Caption: refresh github yeah okay we've got
Caption: internet we can resume the live demo
Caption: uh i guess just log in as the admin user
Caption: so now james is going to explore what
Caption: permissions we've got now that we're
Caption: admin and we'll i showed briefly uh what
Caption: was there
Caption: in the um
Caption: i might have to restart the vpn yeah
Caption: do you remember my password
Caption: all right
Caption: give that a go
Caption: if not we've still got the video backups
Caption: you might have to refresh this to get
Caption: the the login working again
Caption: [Music]
Caption: all right we're in his admin as as we
Caption: were before okay we so we've got this
Caption: admin
Caption: uh menu that we've gained access to and
Caption: there's a number of different buttons on
Caption: there so we've got these server logs it
Caption: the feature is clearly a work in
Caption: progress with some some sample logs in
Caption: there not quite finished we've got some
Caption: notes that we can access these are
Caption: developer notes with a bunch of to-do
Caption: list items
Caption: so the developers mentioned that there's
Caption: an ad product feature that shouldn't be
Caption: using eval for parsing some of you might
Caption: recognize that as a
Caption: interesting thing
Caption: add drop down to the logs page to view
Caption: different log files instead of query
Caption: parameters that's another interesting
Caption: one for us stop using the api as an api
Caption: host as a jump box remove unnecessary
Caption: privileges
Caption: implement a couple of features so
Caption: there's a bunch of cleanup that the
Caption: developers left themselves clearly a
Caption: working product at work in progress
Caption: website we've got the ad product feature
Caption: which we mentioned earlier that we were
Caption: interested in uh so from this page it
Caption: seems like uh you can add a new product
Caption: to the to the page
Caption: to the website
Caption: if we're having trouble
Caption: it's still tethered no okay
Caption: and we've got ad image to gallery which
Caption: is still under construction
Caption: so that seems to be the extent there's
Caption: no there's nothing else obvious that the
Caption: admin seems to have access to so let's
Caption: discuss some of the options that we see
Caption: ahead of us
Caption: uh yes
Caption: we're we're an admin and we've gained
Caption: access to all this but we want to go
Caption: deeper we want to get onto the actual
Caption: host machine
Caption: so how we're going to do that we've got
Caption: a couple of different options
Caption: number one is information disclosure
Caption: this one's relatively self-explanatory
Caption: it means the website discloses
Caption: information that it otherwise shouldn't
Caption: so
Caption: in this case we're looking at the server
Caption: logs feature and we're going to see if
Caption: we can manipulate that into providing us
Caption: with information
Caption: that it otherwise shouldn't be normally
Caption: it should only give us access to logs
Caption: the developer mentioned that there's
Caption: some work still to be done on this page
Caption: so we'll see if we can manipulate that
Caption: to uncover more information which will
Caption: help us get onto the box next up is
Caption: remote code execution this one's a
Caption: pretty severe one to have on your site
Caption: if it does come up
Caption: uh
Caption: everyone probably has heard of vlog for
Caption: shell
Caption: late last year early this year yeah
Caption: caused quite a panic lots of frantic
Caption: patching
Caption: that was an example of remote code
Caption: execution there's a number of different
Caption: ways that remote code execution can come
Caption: up but a very common theme is
Caption: deserialization
Caption: in that case an attacker can craft a
Caption: specially crafted payload
Caption: so maybe a profile profile picture with
Caption: some code in it that's not really a jpeg
Caption: they provide that to the target
Caption: and when the target goes to read that
Caption: data you the attacker will
Caption: has crafted a payload that's exploiting
Caption: the way that it reads that data to then
Caption: get it to do whatever it wants
Caption: potentially die
Caption: in this case we'll be looking at the add
Caption: product feature to see if we can
Caption: manipulate it based on the developer
Caption: notes they mentioned they're using eval
Caption: for parsing the the input from the from
Caption: the user
Caption: so we'll have a look and see if we can
Caption: manipulate that to run whatever code
Caption: we'd like
Caption: so once again we have come to a decision
Caption: point
Caption: vote on your phones for whichever option
Caption: so for those at the back the code is
Caption: 169648
Caption: if you need it
Caption: we'll give it a minute for
Caption: people to have the url loaded up
Caption: all right
Caption: hopefully the results should be off on
Caption: the other side
Caption: if we're tethered we should be able to
Caption: actually see the results ourselves this
Caption: time
Caption: all right looks like a pretty clear win
Caption: for remote code execution
Caption: thanks for all your votes
Caption: we'll proceed with that option live now
Caption: all right so james is now going to do do
Caption: a demo of this hopefully we can do it
Caption: live and not use the video recording so
Caption: james is now navigating to the add
Caption: product feature
Caption: and he's turning on burp again which we
Caption: saw in the previous
Caption: previous layer
Caption: and james is just going to enter some
Caption: data into this form it doesn't really
Caption: matter
Caption: and he's going to submit
Caption: oh yeah
Caption: turn the vpn back on
Caption: and submit
Caption: and now we can see the request has been
Caption: intercepted by burp again we've got this
Caption: options request which we're not
Caption: interested in we go ahead to the post
Caption: request and james is now sending that to
Caption: repeater for us to
Caption: repeat the request
Caption: so now if jane scrolls down in the
Caption: request we can see the actual payload
Caption: that he submitted in the form
Caption: and what he's going to do now is he's
Caption: going to update that payload to
Caption: something else we're going to try and
Caption: see if we can get remote code execution
Caption: so he's just put in just a string there
Caption: see what we get back out of the api
Caption: we get a 500 internal server error
Caption: unexpected identifier okay
Caption: not particularly helpful to us
Caption: now james is going to do a random shot
Caption: in the dark
Caption: see have a look if uh you're missing the
Caption: one yep
Caption: we're just going to see if one equals
Caption: equals one
Caption: if we get any sort of uh
Caption: parsing of that input and returning as
Caption: true so we get a 200 okay from the api
Caption: and
Caption: okay maybe the error codes could use
Caption: some work it says parsed input could not
Caption: be read correctly with the
Caption: additional information being true
Caption: that us hints that we've got some sort
Caption: of remote code execution because the one
Caption: equals equals one
Caption: has has been evaluated as true
Caption: instead of maybe just being interpreted
Caption: as a string
Caption: so now what james is going to do is try
Caption: and identify what we're working with
Caption: here if you if you google eval
Caption: the top two results are javascript and
Caption: python so james is just going to try a
Caption: quick javascript
Caption: command here and see if we get a
Caption: response back
Caption: so we get a 200 okay and we now have
Caption: what appears to be the current working
Caption: directory of the running process
Caption: uh hopefully everyone can see that but
Caption: it says
Caption: basically we see what looks like a
Caption: folder path
Caption: there
Caption: so now that we've identified that we're
Caption: working with javascript and we've got
Caption: remote code execution
Caption: the rest is relatively simple you can go
Caption: by a
Caption: playbook so what james is doing now is
Caption: installing a tool called netcat this is
Caption: a tool that we'll be using to
Caption: set up a remote shell we're using the
Caption: yum package manager here assuming that
Caption: we're working with an ec2 instance
Caption: because the front end was s3 it's a
Caption: relatively safe assumption that the back
Caption: end is ec2 which
Caption: allows us to use yum
Caption: in this case we've we're using a child
Caption: process to run the command so we're not
Caption: actually getting any
Caption: immediate um response back
Caption: so at this stage we're working a little
Caption: bit blind this is a very common theme
Caption: for these sorts of things is you will
Caption: set something up and assume that that
Caption: has worked when you go on to your next
Caption: step
Caption: and you'll find out at the next step if
Caption: it actually worked correctly
Caption: what james is now setting up is using
Caption: netcat which we just installed to set up
Caption: a bind shell listening on port 8181
Caption: we'll explain more about these reverse
Caption: shells and bind shells in a second
Caption: again we don't get any immediate
Caption: response back
Caption: because this is working through a child
Caption: process we're just going to have to
Caption: assume that it's worked and we're now
Caption: going to try and connect to the target
Caption: uh
Caption: yeah in a new tab james is now going to
Caption: run that and we don't get any immediate
Caption: response but if james runs who am i it
Caption: seems we're root on the target we're in
Caption: the in the folder that we saw earlier
Caption: and we've got access to the files there
Caption: so it looks like we're on the actual
Caption: target james is now just going to
Caption: upgrade our shell to something a little
Caption: bit nicer
Caption: there we go so we're root on 10.00.10
Caption: and we're in the in the folder now you
Caption: can see there so we're in we're in as a
Caption: on the host machine now
Caption: we can skip straight to remote shells
Caption: yep so what we've set up currently is a
Caption: bind shell uh in the commands that james
Caption: run he ran he set up netcat and he
Caption: configured it on the target to listen
Caption: for an incoming connection on port 8181
Caption: and then the attacker
Caption: that's uh my laptop here connects
Caption: directly to that ip address on that port
Caption: and now we have a connection the inverse
Caption: of this is a reverse shell where you set
Caption: up the attacker to listen so i would set
Caption: up a process on the laptop to listen and
Caption: then get the actual target to reach back
Caption: out to me this is much more common in
Caption: practice because you it doesn't require
Caption: nearly as much knowledge about the
Caption: target you don't need to know the ip
Caption: address of your target for it to reach
Caption: out to you just has to have internet
Caption: connectivity
Caption: you don't need to have a port available
Caption: on the target to bind to because you're
Caption: you're only listening on your actual
Caption: attacker
Caption: either way the end result is the same we
Caption: have a connection between the attacker
Caption: and the target and we as the attacker
Caption: can tell the target to do whatever we
Caption: want it to do
Caption: now onto eval let's reflect a little bit
Caption: on what the developer was doing here we
Caption: don't have access to the code but we can
Caption: more or less guess that they they knew
Caption: this was wrong because they left
Caption: themselves a note to remove the use of
Caption: eval
Caption: but they also
Caption: had this hidden behind the the admin
Caption: role they were the admin of the website
Caption: probably and only admins could access
Caption: this feature so why
Caption: worry about locking it down it's not
Caption: customer facing anyway
Caption: however yes they did know it was wrong
Caption: if you google eval javascript the top
Caption: five results are all various warnings
Caption: about not using eval so don't do what
Caption: this developer did
Caption: yep never use eval
Caption: you should instead use a json parsing
Caption: library to pass json under the hood
Caption: probably a lot of them do end up using
Caption: eval at some point but they do all sorts
Caption: of validation and make sure that you're
Caption: not giving it anything nasty
Caption: before just running code
Caption: so that's it for that layer of the demo
Caption: i'm now going to hop back on the
Caption: keyboard and james is going to narrate
Caption: while i explore our new found
Caption: permissions
Caption: yeah right so we're now on the host
Caption: it's an ec2 instance so we're actually
Caption: on aws infrastructure
Caption: so the natural next step for us is going
Caption: to be to um try to see what um stuff we
Caption: can get to in the aws account
Caption: um so one natural target would be
Caption: querying secrets manager for secrets
Caption: that are available and seeing if we can
Caption: read any so this is a aws cli command
Caption: that's going to do exactly that
Caption: um so we can see a list of secrets that
Caption: have been returned so that means we have
Caption: the list secrets permission doesn't
Caption: guarantee that we have permission to
Caption: read it
Caption: so there's a secret here that clearly
Caption: catches our eyes super duper top secret
Caption: so let's see if we can read that
Caption: right so this is the cli command that we
Caption: need to use to actually query the
Caption: contents of that secret
Caption: and we get an access denied exception um
Caption: so that is an aws iom error that tells
Caption: us that we're not authorized to access
Caption: that resource
Caption: so next thing we're going to do is we're
Caption: going to do a little bit of recon we're
Caption: going to try to figure out what
Caption: permissions we do have and see if
Caption: there's a way we can escalate our
Caption: privileges
Caption: so james is just querying the metadata
Caption: endpoint that the ec2 instance has
Caption: access to to find out the name of the
Caption: role that it's using
Caption: and then
Caption: attached to an ir role in aws can be one
Caption: or more policies which are documents
Caption: that define permissions so now we're
Caption: going to look at the role policies that
Caption: are attached to that role and we can
Caption: only see one
Caption: so now the next thing we're going to do
Caption: is actually query the policy document um
Caption: that that role
Caption: that that policy contains
Caption: and we can see a whole bunch of
Caption: permissions here
Caption: when we scroll up we can see that we do
Caption: have the secrets manager get secret
Caption: value permission
Caption: assigned to us but it's scoped to these
Caption: resources that um that have these arn
Caption: prefixes um and our super duper top
Caption: secret is not among that list
Caption: um we do however have a big list of
Caption: permissions here um that we do have ec2
Caption: run instances is one that catches our
Caption: eye as is create policy version
Caption: um and if you scroll down a little bit
Caption: more
Caption: i am pass roll
Caption: um and if we keep scrolling we can see
Caption: as well that um the resource section of
Caption: that um is a wild card so we can execute
Caption: these permissions on any resource in the
Caption: account
Caption: all right so
Caption: that gives us our third goal which is to
Caption: start exfol trading secrets um so we
Caption: want to get this super duper top secret
Caption: first role to do that or first option to
Caption: do that is to use the past role
Caption: permission um so the purpose of this is
Caption: that it allows one resource to pass a
Caption: role to another so say you're
Caption: provisioning an ec2 instance
Caption: you can give it a role
Caption: and then if we were to leverage that we
Caption: could then connect into that ec2
Caption: instance via ssh
Caption: and then as we're doing currently with
Caption: the api host we can just use the
Caption: role that it has
Caption: available second option is create policy
Caption: version uh despite the name this is just
Caption: an update policy um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: permission so what it allows us to do is
Caption: create a new version of a policy so at
Caption: the moment if we query secrets manager
Caption: uh we get an access denied error because
Caption: we don't have the permission to access
Caption: it but what we can do based on what
Caption: we've found is we can just update that
Caption: policy to allow us to do it
Caption: and then next time we try to query it we
Caption: should be able to do that
Caption: all right so time to vote um once again
Caption: if you're at the back of the room the
Caption: code is 939765
Caption: um and again we're just going to go
Caption: until we have an authoritative result
Caption: not until every single vote it comes in
Caption: got one or two phones still up we'll
Caption: wait till
Caption: all right
Caption: have a look at the results
Caption: oh this one's pretty tight oh boy
Caption: it's a dead head all right it kind of
Caption: looks like create policy version is
Caption: winning by a hair but we'll
Caption: if anyone's still
Caption: trying to vote
Caption: is this it any tie breakers coming in
Caption: all right all right i'll take the
Caption: silences
Caption: oh
Caption: there's one close up
Caption: we'll give it five more seconds
Caption: someone open up incognito on your on
Caption: your browser and do a second vote
Caption: it looks like create policy versions one
Caption: only just that's the closest we've seen
Caption: it
Caption: all right so create policy version has
Caption: it so let's go do that and see if we can
Caption: get that secret
Caption: all right so what we're going to do now
Caption: is create a new version of the policy
Caption: that's attached to our role so first
Caption: thing we're going to do is go back to
Caption: that query that we used before to list
Caption: the policies that are attached to the
Caption: role
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: the name of the policy that we're after
Caption: is simple policy it's the only one there
Caption: and we've got the arn of it there which
Caption: we're going to need to make a command to
Caption: update it
Caption: right so this is one very big inline
Caption: command that james is going to paste in
Caption: that's going to do the update operation
Caption: but
Caption: um i will talk to it piece by piece
Caption: right so
Caption: first line of the thing there the first
Caption: main argument is that arn that we just
Caption: looked up which is the uh policy that
Caption: we're going to be updating
Caption: um following that you can see the actual
Caption: policy document we've just pasted it
Caption: there as inline json um most important
Caption: parts are this statement here that
Caption: contains the
Caption: actions section that says secrets
Caption: manager list secrets and secrets manager
Caption: gets secret value so that's going to
Caption: allow us to get the secret value and
Caption: importantly we've got a wild card for
Caption: the resource section so this policy will
Caption: have
Caption: permission to read any secret that's in
Caption: the account
Caption: um finally we can see set as default
Caption: that's just another flag we set which
Caption: makes that the default version that's
Caption: going to be used by any role that isn't
Caption: pinned to a specific version of the
Caption: policy
Caption: our shell's a little wonky which is why
Caption: you can see all the uh
Caption: all the commands are repeated a second
Caption: time
Caption: right so having run that uh it succeeded
Caption: we didn't get any errors and we now have
Caption: a new version of the policy there
Caption: version three
Caption: and because it we gave it set as default
Caption: it is now the default um
Caption: right so now we're just going to go back
Caption: to the cli command that we ran before to
Caption: get the secret value and see if it works
Caption: so it did work we didn't get the same
Caption: error and we have in secret string here
Caption: the actual content of the secret
Caption: now in this case this is just a flag but
Caption: obviously in a real application it could
Caption: be something far more interesting like
Caption: database credentials or really anything
Caption: um also worth calling out at this point
Caption: that um although we just used our powers
Caption: to
Caption: give ourselves access to read any secret
Caption: in the account we do effectively have
Caption: admin access we could have written any
Caption: policy that allowed any or all um aws
Caption: api actions um and that would have been
Caption: accepted and we would have those
Caption: permissions
Caption: all right
Caption: so how do we get here oh
Caption: right so
Caption: um let's just reflect a little bit on
Caption: what the developer did right and wrong
Caption: oh actually first off we're going to
Caption: talk about automation because
Caption: we just did that by hand
Caption: and we were lucky in that we had
Caption: permissions in our role to list the
Caption: policies that are attached to the role
Caption: and to query the granular permissions
Caption: that that policy consists of
Caption: if you don't have that there are tools
Caption: available um that can do it for you um
Caption: examples being weird al pacu and red
Caption: bodo and what they'll basically do is
Caption: hit the aws api using your credentials
Caption: probe it and they can distinguish from
Caption: the error messages that they get whether
Caption: you actually have that permission or not
Caption: um so if you're working blind those
Caption: tools really help you out
Caption: all right now we're gonna reflect on
Caption: what the developer
Caption: should have done
Caption: the main thing is they should have
Caption: applied the principle of least privilege
Caption: this being an api host it should have
Caption: had one clear role and only had
Caption: permissions it needed for that so they
Caption: should have segregated the duties that
Caption: ec2 instance shouldn't be spinning up by
Caption: the infrastructure nor should it be
Caption: manipulating i am policies
Caption: um
Caption: and another recommendation would be
Caption: don't put wild cards in your iam
Caption: policies scope them as granular as you
Caption: can to the actual resources that you do
Caption: need to manipulate
Caption: and that brings us to the end of the
Caption: live demo of the pen test
Caption: so what did we learn
Caption: we learned to sanitize and control user
Caption: inputs wherever they arise
Caption: follow the principle of least privilege
Caption: like james just mentioned applied
Caption: defense in depth this is particularly
Caption: irrelevant especially to that that
Caption: second and third layer where the
Caption: developer left themselves a bit of a
Caption: mess some notes they said to themselves
Caption: well this thing's a bit buggy it's a bit
Caption: vulnerable but it's not customer facing
Caption: anyway i'm the admin who what could go
Caption: wrong
Caption: you should always be assuming that well
Caption: you shouldn't always assume that your
Caption: defenses will fail but you should aim to
Caption: minimize blast radius whenever someone
Caption: can get into one layer to prevent them
Caption: from being able to exploit that to get
Caption: further access
Caption: ideally if there weren't those bugs in
Caption: that for that second layer the
Caption: an attacker that got in
Caption: through the the first bug which was the
Caption: mass assignment wouldn't be able to then
Caption: get onto the actual api host through
Caption: further exploitation they would just be
Caption: able to read the to-do list and that
Caption: would be about it
Caption: the rest of the learnings depends on the
Caption: path we took so i hope you were paying
Caption: attention during the various reflections
Caption: different paths would would have had
Caption: different key takeaways
Caption: how can you get into this like i
Caption: promised we're hoping to expire at least
Caption: some of the audience to participate in
Caption: this sort of thing uh try hack me and
Caption: hack the box are both really valuable
Caption: resources that i've personally really
Caption: enjoyed
Caption: i spent about a year working with eric
Caption: who's in the room on various
Caption: hack-the-box exercises they were lots of
Caption: fun
Caption: really satisfying to break into
Caption: particular shout out to ipsec tutorials
Caption: whenever a box gets retired you can be
Caption: sure that there's a really useful
Caption: and thorough video tutorial on how to
Caption: break into that box will go up on
Caption: youtube immediately after
Caption: pentester lab and os juice drop are
Caption: other things that i haven't used
Caption: personally but have had recommendations
Caption: for
Caption: there are also some certs you can aim
Caption: for in this space not really for the
Caption: beginners but something to maybe aspire
Caption: for
Caption: i'm also interested in going for these
Caption: myself oscp and ceh
Caption: offensive security certified
Caption: professional and certified ethical
Caption: hacker that was a mouthful uh
Caption: interesting certs that i think anyone in
Caption: this space could be interested in aiming
Caption: for eventually and then like james and i
Caption: mentioned wacts or wsctf or really any
Caption: ctfs are a great environment to get
Caption: exposed to all sorts of things related
Caption: to pen testing or cyber in general
Caption: and they're a great environment like
Caption: full very supportive community and just
Caption: a great area to learn about these sorts
Caption: of things other than being left out in
Caption: the foyer when you arrive late
Caption: finally we'd like to give a big thanks
Caption: to all the sponsors of ddd without which
Caption: this talk would not have been possible
Caption: so thank you very much and that's all
Caption: from us
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: we've got about five minutes left in
Caption: this session if anyone has a question
Caption: for james down the back
Caption: hi um
Caption: yes so
Caption: let's say you're just a graduate
Caption: postgrad or undergrad cyber security
Caption: student so to further increase improve
Caption: your chances and having no internship
Caption: available made to you you just do some
Caption: more ctfs and then try and get
Caption: some more certifications and then
Caption: fingers crossed and the company will
Caption: look at you even though you don't have
Caption: any years of experience
Caption: to employ you as a pen testers etc
Caption: um to be clear neither james nor i are
Caption: professional pen testers um
Caption: but
Caption: yeah
Caption: in terms of looking for jobs most of
Caption: most of the pen testers i know are
Caption: actually
Caption: ones who went in from software
Caption: engineering
Caption: that's not necessarily the only path uh
Caption: obviously now more and more there's more
Caption: focus on on
Caption: cyber security
Caption: studies um and you could potentially get
Caption: into that via entry-level roles i'm
Caption: most of the pen testers i know are not
Caption: so entry level though i don't know i
Caption: feel like there's probably more
Caption: analyst roles that would be a suitable
Caption: start
Caption: would be my my gut instinct but i
Caption: haven't done a huge amount of research
Caption: into actually becoming a pen tester can
Caption: i also add there's a thousand people
Caption: here today and so there's going to be a
Caption: few people in the room there's certainly
Caption: some of the organizations are recruiting
Caption: so the more people you meet today the
Caption: better your chances are of finding that
Caption: we've got another question from anyone
Caption: cool
Caption: thanks for the talk today guys um
Caption: so my question is i appreciate that both
Caption: of you guys are in software engineering
Caption: not um cyber at the moment but um my
Caption: question is in an enterprise pen test
Caption: um how do you know the scope of which to
Caption: you know basically attack the system
Caption: you're trying to you're trying to attest
Caption: to because obviously you could spend
Caption: lots of time and eventually break in but
Caption: you probably have limited resources in
Caption: limited time so
Caption: yeah i mean that
Caption: that really ends up being an agreement
Caption: between the the pentester and the
Caption: teste
Caption: um so
Caption: yeah that that varies i know certainly
Caption: when i was working at bankwest there's
Caption: all sorts of um
Caption: meetings with the team beforehand where
Caption: you talk about what the exact scope of
Caption: the work will be and i'm sure the same
Caption: can be applied to basically any pen test
Caption: right you you agree with the client
Caption: what the scope for the pen test is how
Caption: long you're going to spend on it
Caption: um
Caption: you've probably as a pen test you've
Caption: probably got a playbook of like a very
Caption: systematic approach to testing all sorts
Caption: of vulnerabilities
Caption: and you go through those and if you find
Caption: stuff you find stuff and you report
Caption: those back if you don't you don't
Caption: and then yeah the depth at which your
Caption: your pen testing again would be
Caption: something agreed on
Caption: probably prior to the test unless maybe
Caption: you're doing a pure red teaming exercise
Caption: in which case
Caption: uh potentially all bars are off but
Caption: uh
Caption: unlikely
Caption: awesome um we've probably got time for
Caption: one more question if there's anyone else
Caption: can i ask a question then there is a
Caption: question
Caption: more an observation really but um i've
Caption: been in software development for a while
Caption: and there's almost no code base that
Caption: doesn't have any kind of vulnerability
Caption: or something if you look look and dig
Caption: deep enough so there's always something
Caption: to find no matter where you're looking
Caption: yeah absolutely yeah i would 100 agree
Caption: that's kind of just a quick comment as
Caption: well as that's obviously another
Caption: argument for applying defense in depth
Caption: and just making sure that uh if any
Caption: layer of your architecture does get
Caption: breached that you kind of minimize the
Caption: the risk that that poses to other layers
Caption: and i'd assume that's where the um
Caption: bounty hunting and the rewards come from
Caption: for a lot of these organizations i've
Caption: seen so you if you're looking for a job
Caption: in this space then go for a bounty
Caption: hunting
Caption: expedition another pen testing adventure
Caption: can i have another round of applause for
Caption: james one and james two thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you
Caption: so there's about 10 minutes until the
Caption: next session if you need to change rooms
Caption: please do get in there quickly
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: please
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use zero can do that yeah but it
Caption: needs to be secure we can't have our app
Caption: compromised by breaches not a problem
Caption: and it needs to scale if we get hit with
Caption: a ton of traffic and if it stalls or
Caption: freezes up i will get fired we can do
Caption: this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: god
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pinkberry
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet it's when people ask me how to
Caption: pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow
Caption: but i also get a lot of training
Caption: opportunities and planning because
Caption: there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really
Caption: good that planet offers these free
Caption: courses for me and i don't have to feel
Caption: pressured about buying something just so
Caption: i can improve my skills and use them for
Caption: work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's really cool to be around
Caption: people who are so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better um i think that's really
Caption: important and i think it's going to be a
Caption: driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top learning is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's about web apis and
Caption: two-factor authentication um you might
Caption: also want to talk about making simple
Caption: easy which was in a's talk also in this
Caption: room at the same time
Caption: we don't know where that is at the
Caption: moment but i'm sure we'll figure things
Caption: out i'm delighted to introduce phil and
Caption: uh take it away thank you very much uh
Caption: yes yes i am not the originally
Caption: scheduled person in here and i hope
Caption: that's okay with you all i won't try and
Caption: give that person slide deck though i
Caption: have my own
Caption: and today i want to talk about well i'm
Caption: calling it secrets of the credential
Caption: management apis now has anybody heard of
Caption: the credential management apis before a
Caption: handset that's one two three okay that's
Caption: actually five is more than normally put
Caption: it up but for those of but for the rest
Caption: of you uh i i guess it's not so much
Caption: secrets of these apis but the apis have
Caption: been sort of kept a secret from you uh a
Caption: little bit uh and um and we'll we'll dig
Caption: into a bit of that uh soon now i also
Caption: realize this is a 20 minute talk i might
Caption: talk a little fast because uh the last
Caption: time he gave this this was about half an
Caption: hour so let's crack on with it my name's
Caption: phil nash i am a developer evangelist at
Caption: a company called twilio if you want to
Caption: learn about twilio or talk to me again
Caption: later i have a booth on the other side
Caption: there opposite the coffee stand so come
Caption: say hi to me there or catch me online i
Caption: am filmmash all over the internet uh
Caption: twitter linkedin whatever or hit me up
Caption: on email filmmastertoyo.com
Caption: um
Caption: i have a question already
Caption: i love it right
Caption: i will pay anything to have my domain
Caption: name like that also some phil nash has
Caption: got filmatch.com and it's holding onto
Caption: it and doing nothing with it anymore so
Caption: but this is better this is better
Caption: um cool so what i want to kind of talk
Caption: about is like better authentication
Caption: experiences i have this concern that uh
Caption: when we build applications on the web uh
Caption: that uh the important and interesting
Caption: things that we work on are you know um
Caption: the applications are actually building
Caption: that that thing beyond the login
Caption: experience the thing that users actually
Caption: want to get to and the login tends to be
Caption: um
Caption: friction the thing that goes in the way
Caption: of of people getting to do the stuff uh
Caption: that they actually uh care about uh and
Caption: i want to improve that um because
Caption: so i was looking at some data uh a while
Caption: back uh and um
Caption: this 24 number comes from a survey that
Caption: google did at the end of 2018 uh about
Caption: kind of security uh things that users do
Caption: and 24 was the number of people who use
Caption: a password manager uh from that uh
Caption: survey uh 24 not bad actually pretty
Caption: good number but that still means three
Caption: quarters of people are not using a
Caption: password manager which sort of is bad
Caption: because
Caption: these passwords right uh in fact um
Caption: and i do want to kind of prefix this by
Caption: the fact that you know we're probably
Caption: developers or power users of computers
Caption: and our laptops uh in our daily work and
Caption: we probably are amongst those 24 that do
Caption: use a password manager or in fact have
Caption: um
Caption: worked on your own login experience so
Caption: that you don't have to worry about that
Caption: it's normally a click you don't have to
Caption: know your own password but that's not
Caption: the case for most people and that's my
Caption: point here um
Caption: this uh awkward sort of flow diagram
Caption: kind of is is the experience of somebody
Caption: logging into a website right and it
Caption: starts at the top where you hit the
Caption: login page right there and immediately
Caption: you ask yourself do i know my username
Caption: because that's not necessarily clear now
Caption: sometimes it's your email sometimes it's
Caption: something else and if you don't you have
Caption: to go through a nice little username
Caption: refl um uh username reset passflow
Caption: if you've got past the uh like username
Caption: like if the answer to this is yes and or
Caption: indeed maybe
Caption: because you can never tell until you put
Caption: it in and we get to do i know my
Caption: password and again that's the same
Caption: problem maybe you do maybe you don't if
Caption: you've got in a password manager you're
Caption: probably fine but if you are not if
Caption: you're a regular user if you're one of
Caption: the 74 of 76 of people not using one do
Caption: you know your password who knows maybe
Caption: have to go through a reset flow uh if
Caption: you think you know both of those you can
Caption: enter them in and hope for the best at
Caption: which point you find out whether you
Caption: knew your email address sorry your
Caption: username and password and either go back
Caption: to the start and maybe go through one of
Caption: the reset flows again or you get on and
Caption: maybe hit a two-factor notification
Caption: challenge because this is a secure site
Caption: and uh and then a text message is sent
Caption: to your phone your phone's in another
Caption: room you give up you close the computer
Caption: you throw it out the window um
Caption: that's that's a sort of regular user
Caption: flow of logging into a website
Caption: um
Caption: that's the two factors that indicate
Caption: message right yeah sure the user
Caption: experience of this uh ends up being um i
Caption: i have a scale of like zero to poop
Caption: emoji on this and it's just poop emoji
Caption: that's
Caption: this is not a scientific scale it's just
Caption: how i like to think about things um
Caption: it's a bad user experience and we can
Caption: make it better um because it's full of
Caption: friction that's what i'm kind of talking
Caption: about it's full of that like do i know
Caption: my username do i know my password
Caption: am i right about either of those
Caption: and and how long does it take to
Caption: actually get to the thing we wanted to
Caption: do in the first place do we want to buy
Caption: the thing do we want to
Caption: carry on the service whatever
Caption: so i'm going to run us through how we
Caption: can usernames and passwords better real
Caption: quick i'm going to start with the html
Caption: um html can actually help us an awful
Caption: lot in this place it makes the form more
Caption: accessible it makes the experience
Caption: better and quicker um and so this is
Caption: what a login form might look like right
Caption: we've got a fairly straightforward form
Caption: it's got two inputs a a
Caption: a text input for our username a password
Caption: input for our password the labels point
Caption: to the right things it's fine it's quite
Caption: good but there's more we can do to it
Caption: than this
Caption: um the input element itself is one of my
Caption: favorite elements uh in html uh possibly
Caption: my favorite because um because of how
Caption: much uh scope it has the the amount of
Caption: things you can do with a single
Caption: attribute that change the behavior of an
Caption: input element is incredible um
Caption: the attributes available to us some are
Caption: less used than others uh and the ones i
Caption: want to kind of call out here well
Caption: firstly uh the type now you might be
Caption: able to change an important one to a
Caption: checkbox or a radio button or something
Caption: but in this particular case if my form
Caption: was if my username was in fact an email
Caption: address as well then we probably should
Caption: change that type to an email
Caption: uh that's going to help us on a mobile
Caption: device it's going to pop up uh
Caption: the
Caption: keyboard which has an app symbol like
Caption: prominently on it which is useful and
Caption: helps people out and then we've got
Caption: autocomplete autocomplete is going to
Caption: feature quite a bit in this because it's
Caption: the greatest attribute the input element
Caption: has
Caption: uh in this case uh autocomplete username
Caption: and autocomplete current password allow
Caption: us to give hints to the browser and
Caption: indeed to any other technology like a
Caption: password manager that might want to
Caption: autofill these things in for you um
Caption: username is really useful there is also
Caption: order complete email but that's really
Caption: for when you're um dealing with uh
Caption: somebody's actual contact details not
Caption: the thing you're using to log into a
Caption: thing
Caption: um current password is really cool
Caption: because there's also a new password
Caption: autocomplete
Caption: that's particularly useful for your page
Caption: where you're changing your password and
Caption: you have three different password inputs
Caption: on the same page one's for the old
Caption: password and two are for repeating the
Caption: new password um but without new password
Caption: and current password
Caption: uh uh
Caption: browsers or
Caption: password managers will autofill the same
Caption: thing into all three but if you have new
Caption: password and current password then
Caption: they'll be able to offer suggestions the
Caption: new password and the existing one to the
Caption: current password actually firefox itself
Caption: uh offers you a secure suggestion if you
Caption: have autocomplete is new password on an
Caption: input really useful um so don't forget
Caption: about these autocomplete look it up it's
Caption: amazing um i have a little demo of just
Caption: kind of my existing login flow i've got
Caption: a demo application that we're going to
Caption: deal with for the rest of this app and
Caption: all it does is log in which is annoying
Caption: really because the entire app is 100
Caption: friction um but this
Caption: it's got nothing on the other side of it
Caption: it's amazing it's got a log out button
Caption: um but i just want to show you like this
Caption: is the existing uh experience right we
Caption: we go to login we have to do all the
Caption: typing now i happen to know my username
Caption: and password for this uh the password is
Caption: secret
Caption: it's the most secure six character
Caption: password i can think of uh and i'm
Caption: logged in uh in fact i've got a
Caption: two-factor authentication message and
Caption: there it is over the other side um
Caption: eight four three two nine three cool uh
Caption: so i had to look at my phone and then i
Caption: come back over here and oh my goodness
Caption: are we logged in yet yes we're logged in
Caption: cool um go away
Caption: i'll come back to that later um so
Caption: that's that's the sort of that's our
Caption: existing slow i have to type everything
Caption: in version
Caption: so let's see what else we can do that
Caption: had our auto complete attributes on it
Caption: but because i wasn't using any other
Caption: technology to auto complete things that
Caption: didn't show up to help
Caption: but this is where we get to credential
Caption: management and for the people who put
Caption: their
Caption: hands up they know about this it's great
Caption: um
Caption: credential management apis in the
Caption: browsers allow us to store and then
Caption: retrieve our user's credentials um and
Caption: so i was annoyingly clicking away the
Caption: browser pop up there to say i would like
Caption: to would you like to save your username
Caption: and password in this uh but that was
Caption: just kind of the browser doing on its
Caption: own what we can actually hook into is is
Caption: triggering that and then using it later
Caption: because if we
Caption: as a developer as the website trigger
Caption: that app um that pop-up
Caption: we're actually able to retrieve the
Caption: password from a username and password
Caption: from it later and make a smoother login
Caption: flow and i'll show you how that works
Caption: um here's what the code looks like it's
Caption: actually fairly simple
Caption: uh we look for the password credential
Caption: to be in the window object and when we
Caption: have that we can create a password
Caption: credential using
Caption: our user id and password so this is once
Caption: we know uh that the user id and password
Caption: is correct so this could happen at
Caption: registration or on a successful login
Caption: and uh and once we create that
Caption: credential
Caption: um oh hold on i've got things there
Caption: there we go this line a weight navigator
Caption: credentials store credential
Caption: allows you to then
Caption: store it in the uh in the browser's
Caption: credential management browser's password
Caption: manager
Caption: uh and the real power of this is the
Caption: next page where we get to ask for it
Caption: back again so when the user comes to log
Caption: in
Caption: we can go and retrieve those credentials
Caption: we say navigator credentials get uh
Caption: password is true we're asking for
Caption: password in this case and that pops up
Caption: another um
Caption: permissions thing from the browser to
Caption: say
Caption: do you want to log in with these
Caption: credentials
Caption: and
Caption: and if the user approves that then uh
Caption: they are through you can
Caption: write a function that says
Caption: pass them through
Caption: you can actually do this silently as
Caption: well which is which is kind of cool i'm
Caption: not
Caption: necessarily the biggest fan of it but uh
Caption: if um
Caption: uh
Caption: you can kind of do that without the
Caption: permissions dialogue and uh and that
Caption: will pass a user straight through um
Caption: you know get the credentials for them
Caption: and allow you to log them straight in no
Caption: friction whatsoever i think maybe a
Caption: little bit of friction is useful
Caption: and so but you can turn that on with
Caption: unmediated is true here
Caption: um but you can make sure that
Caption: permissions always pop up if say a user
Caption: has specifically logged out uh and so
Caption: when signing out if you call on
Caption: navigator credentials um prevent silent
Caption: access
Caption: uh that's a good thing for you know a
Caption: user properly sign out they don't want
Caption: to be automatically signed in again
Caption: um
Caption: what does this look like i think it's
Caption: it's important to show kind of better
Caption: what this looks like so if i go and log
Caption: out i'm gonna go back through my process
Caption: well one second i need to
Caption: check out the version of the code
Caption: that does this
Caption: credential management there you go
Caption: basically just uncommented a bunch of
Caption: stuff
Caption: um and now if i go and log in this time
Caption: around we're going to see that same
Caption: browser pop up to say hey do you want to
Caption: store your username and password but
Caption: this time i'm asking for that access
Caption: and i will be able to
Caption: use it again later so when we're going
Caption: to log in we know it's successful log in
Caption: because we we've succeeded i'm saving it
Caption: i've got to go to my tv authentication
Caption: we'll cover making that better in a
Caption: second seven
Caption: oh three four three four
Caption: and submit that and i'm through now this
Caption: time i'm going to log out log back in
Caption: again and we see it work
Caption: no
Caption: which one is it
Caption: friction exactly
Caption: well it doesn't help if i'm logging in
Caption: and out a bunch of times but uh it is
Caption: that or i didn't do the right typing
Caption: let's try it one more time
Caption: yeah all right cool i was right i just
Caption: typed it wrong so this time around i
Caption: used that credential management api and
Caption: as i got a successful login i stored the
Caption: thing in the browser uh so if i log out
Caption: again and then go to login it's going to
Caption: know it's me and suggest that in uh sign
Caption: in look at that
Caption: do you want to sign in as film i
Caption: absolutely do
Caption: sign in so we've turned in this
Caption: particular case our sign in process from
Caption: having to remember your username and
Caption: password uh having to type it all in uh
Caption: into a single click a single tap and
Caption: we're through and i'm very excited about
Caption: that uh sadly obviously we've got stuck
Caption: at two-factor authentication again
Caption: um
Caption: which hasn't even come through now oh
Caption: it's nine four one five two five there
Caption: we go
Caption: i have a bank that um
Caption: screams at me every time they send me a
Caption: text message with a code and be like
Caption: never tell anyone this i'm like it times
Caption: out in five minutes
Caption: i will tell people then
Caption: um
Caption: it's true you shouldn't obviously share
Caption: these things oh my god i'm gonna run out
Caption: of time brilliant so we got logged in
Caption: let's go back i'm gonna run out of time
Caption: if i don't get through this so let's
Caption: talk about two facts authentication i
Caption: think it's super important because we
Caption: have these um
Caption: usernames and passwords and people who
Caption: don't use password managers and people
Caption: who uh repeat themselves and use the
Caption: same parcels all the time and the whole
Caption: thing is friction over and over again
Caption: right
Caption: so password reuse this was in the same
Caption: survey that i mentioned at the start uh
Caption: the blue slice of the pie there uh is
Caption: people who reuse passwords some of the
Caption: time
Caption: the yellow slices people who reuse
Caption: passwords all of the time i love that
Caption: the people answering the survey were
Caption: just like how many passwords do i have
Caption: just one i just
Caption: use it everywhere it's the greatest
Caption: password those are the people getting
Caption: hacked all of the time it was 13 of
Caption: people in this particular survey
Caption: 52 said some of the time
Caption: uh 13 said all of the time i reuse
Caption: passwords and then this nice little
Caption: green slice of people who say they never
Caption: reuse passwords 35 percent of people in
Caption: the survey said they never reuse
Caption: passwords i'll remind you that 24 of
Caption: people said that they use a password
Caption: manager so 11 of people have a
Caption: photographic memory or they're lying
Caption: and that's our users for you
Caption: um
Caption: it's a bad experience and so and thus
Caption: you know we also do um that always comes
Caption: up too tiny uh we uh the problem about
Caption: this is is our problem we've put all
Caption: these problem problematic password
Caption: things in the way of people uh your
Caption: password must contain at least eight
Caption: letters a capital a protagonist with
Caption: good character development a twist and a
Caption: happy ending
Caption: if you consider you'll never remember
Caption: that past or maybe you'll only ever
Caption: remember that password it's a great
Caption: story
Caption: um but what this actually you know the
Caption: real the real things we do is say we
Caption: must have a capital letter uh some
Caption: lowercase letters a number and a special
Caption: character right and this is the perfect
Caption: password for that because it does
Caption: everything it's got eight characters
Caption: it's got 10 characters in it look at
Caption: that enormously long password
Caption: but this gives um attackers an easy way
Caption: to um patternize things it's a
Caption: dictionary word which starts with a
Caption: capital letter ends with the number one
Caption: because why would you think beyond one
Caption: and uses the exclamation point because
Caption: it's a special character but it uses the
Caption: same key as number one you don't even
Caption: have to move your finger when you're
Caption: typing it in
Caption: and so when you have patterns like this
Caption: it makes it easier to brute force attack
Caption: this kind of thing and that's a bad
Caption: thing and then on the other hand uh
Caption: there are sites leaking our data all out
Caption: over the place um and and if you don't
Caption: know how ibmpone.com uh uh that's that
Caption: gathers those uh leaks those breaches
Caption: and shares just tell you whether your
Caption: password has been part of that and yes
Caption: it has
Caption: um
Caption: so either other people are leaking our
Caption: passwords or users are using the same
Caption: password or they're using an easily
Caption: broken password and so that's why we
Caption: have two-factor authentication so we can
Caption: have one extra factor one other reason
Caption: to believe that this person is the right
Caption: person signing in uh and hooray for
Caption: two-factor um but the user experience
Caption: remains on the poop scale of
Caption: poop
Caption: uh because it's still more friction like
Caption: i said we've watched me struggle to
Caption: enter a code several times just today
Caption: and so let's make it better we can
Caption: actually help these get auto-completed
Caption: and autofilled in again so i'm going
Caption: back to the html and go back to
Caption: autocomplete because on the input when
Caption: you have a code if you include
Caption: autocomplete is one-time code then in
Caption: safari uh when your text message comes
Caption: through uh it comes up in that little
Caption: autocomplete but on the um
Caption: keyboard autocomplete on the keyboard
Caption: right and it's just this one little
Caption: attribute that allows that to happen and
Caption: it's wonderful if you've not seen it
Caption: before it looks like this you go to
Caption: login you get the message sent to you
Caption: and uh and as you enter just go to the
Caption: into the code there it is boom all right
Caption: it's too quick there's no friction
Caption: it's wonderful um and and so you only
Caption: need that one little thing for it so
Caption: there it is coming up in the top of the
Caption: keyboard there
Caption: and you just hit that it enters with
Caption: through it's glorious
Caption: we can do some other things to make this
Caption: nicer uh if your one-time code
Caption: input is a text input then you're going
Caption: to see the keyboard for text which is
Caption: not a good thing because it's normally
Caption: six digits that we're entering
Caption: and so if you actually add like input
Caption: mode as numeric uh it's going to make
Caption: that a better experience for people who
Caption: can't auto complete because that brings
Caption: you up
Caption: with your number keypad much nicer
Caption: number keypad
Caption: so
Caption: let's think about that and then what
Caption: about the desktop i mean this is only
Caption: safari right now and that was only ios
Caption: that that showed up there but actually
Caption: if you happen to be a big safari fan
Caption: and have your um desktop safari set up
Caption: as well uh this actually works across to
Caption: the desktop um and i'm gonna hold up
Caption: look at that
Caption: um the
Caption: when the message comes through to your
Caption: iphone if you've got imessage like set
Caption: up onto your device as well it's going
Caption: to do the autocomplete on your desktop
Caption: as long as you're in safari
Caption: right so what's the other thing web otp
Caption: is our is our final thing here uh this
Caption: is the sort of chrome android and
Caption: pushing to a um
Caption: web standard solution for this uh and it
Caption: allows actually a bit more security in
Caption: this like that autocomplete kind of sort
Caption: of works and but it really does actually
Caption: just see a text message see like six
Caption: digits in it and assume everything else
Caption: works whereas web otp is a bit more
Caption: strict than that um it enforces that uh
Caption: the messages you send uh the two-factor
Caption: authentication code into have two bits
Caption: at the end of it uh an at symbol
Caption: followed by the domain name on which the
Caption: person should be logging in and then a
Caption: hash symbol and then the code now the at
Caption: symbol on the domain allows the browser
Caption: and the operating system to agree
Caption: to autocomplete on this site and this
Caption: site only which is a good fishing
Caption: defense right if you are being fished
Caption: for your two-factor authentication code
Caption: uh
Caption: you're on a different domain and
Caption: therefore this will not offer the
Caption: autocomplete for it because it doesn't
Caption: match up so it's a security thing to
Caption: actually use this
Caption: which is very nice
Caption: um so
Caption: uh web otp actually uses that very same
Caption: credential management api uh looks a
Caption: little like this like this and instead
Caption: of asking for the password in this case
Caption: uh we asked for the otp transport of sms
Caption: i really like this because um that's an
Caption: array which can have one element in it
Caption: which is the string sms
Caption: which is which is cool um
Caption: you've got loads of options there to go
Caption: in that array um so let's see that in
Caption: action uh i'm going to go to the demo
Caption: and this time bring up the phone i'm
Caption: going to do this on the phone this time
Caption: uh
Caption: assuming we can get a browser there we
Caption: go so if i go back and refresh this
Caption: login page firstly what you'll notice is
Caption: that because i'm in logged in in both my
Caption: google account uh my chrome account on
Caption: both the desktop and the phone that it's
Caption: already synced my username and password
Caption: across so that is already still a
Caption: one-tap process to get through the
Caption: username and password section and now no
Caption: i didn't restart the server no
Caption: i need to
Caption: try that again
Caption: oops
Caption: because that wouldn't have had the code
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: i'm going to go back to login start
Caption: again i don't know
Caption: back to login we get off at the login
Caption: this time it's going to send me the text
Caption: message
Caption: and offer me to auto complete that text
Caption: so it's coming into the text and there's
Caption: the permissions dialogue to say hey do
Caption: you want to read this and enter the code
Caption: and we allow it we get access to the
Caption: code and we're through our login
Caption: has gone from typing typing typing
Caption: finding the phone and getting in there
Caption: to tap to yes log me in
Caption: and tap yes use that code i think that's
Caption: cool um
Caption: but you might be asking
Caption: what about the desktop in this
Caption: particular case
Caption: and um
Caption: uh the desktop actually works as well
Caption: it's very cool um i hope it works so it
Caption: can be a bit finicky but if you are in
Caption: chrome uh in your android device and uh
Caption: your browser
Caption: and they all agree with each other that
Caption: you're the same person
Caption: then the mobile device will offer you up
Caption: to copy across the code that has arrived
Caption: from the text message into the browser
Caption: it tends to require the the devices to
Caption: be on the same network as well that has
Caption: failed for me in the past and i have not
Caption: yet managed to check because this is a
Caption: last minute talk haven't managed to
Caption: check if this works on this network but
Caption: cross your fingers for me we're going to
Caption: go and log in we're going to sign in
Caption: with a one tap and what we should see is
Caption: the text message coming over here on the
Caption: right hand side
Caption: and then an offer to copy that across
Caption: or
Caption: just crash the browser in the background
Caption: amazing
Caption: that was unexpected um
Caption: let's let's
Caption: let's give it one more attempt at that
Caption: uh i'm gonna log in with that it doesn't
Caption: need the browser to be open this is just
Caption: the the um
Caption: the device doing it and so the message
Caption: should arrive and then it should give me
Caption: the option there we go submit this code
Caption: on the other computer if i press submit
Caption: there i'm hands off for the other side
Caption: we submit the code and it enters it and
Caption: logs me in
Caption: um so
Caption: uh the security there like you have to
Caption: be able you have to you know say that
Caption: that code is allowed to go from this
Caption: device to the computer and yeah if
Caption: you're not on the same network and
Caption: things like that it's not going to offer
Caption: that up um but now our two-factor
Caption: authentication is just a
Caption: it's much less friction
Caption: uh so it works across the desktop as
Caption: well at least if you're in chrome and
Caption: chrome
Caption: uh just talking a little bit about the
Caption: future like i i kind of um laugh at the
Caption: idea that we have this uh single
Caption: array
Caption: uh that has one potential element to it
Caption: but i like this because it's the way
Caption: that web gets uh designed and designed
Caption: well it's it's designed for
Caption: extensibility and if we come up with
Caption: other transports and other ways to get
Caption: an otp code from a device uh we can add
Caption: to this api and so i hope uh this is
Caption: something that can be built to deal with
Caption: authenticator apps or indeed um other
Caption: device-based uh
Caption: authentication
Caption: uh being able to web or then maybe from
Caption: a from a phone to a to a desktop
Caption: anything like that um this is extensible
Caption: and ready but in general i think uh
Caption: these little these little changes these
Caption: little tweaks credential management api
Caption: and the autocomplete kind of things that
Caption: we have available to us allow us to uh
Caption: enhance and progressively enhance
Caption: because it doesn't work everywhere that
Caption: progressively enhance the experience for
Caption: login and uh and i'd i'd recommend that
Caption: you take another look at your own login
Caption: flows and see if you can reduce the
Caption: friction for your users when they're
Caption: getting into the into your application
Caption: um that's uh that was a bit quick but
Caption: hopefully that was interesting that my
Caption: name is monash i'm a developer advanced
Caption: at twilio and i would love to talk and
Caption: meet you over at my stand sometime later
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you phil um if anyone's seen a
Caption: lightning talk they're about half as
Caption: slow as phil
Caption: um but for a last minute ring in and to
Caption: fit into that time slot is pretty
Caption: amazing so can we have one more round of
Caption: applause thank you still nationally
Caption: thank you
Caption: we're about to kick off the next
Caption: sessions in this room we have the mother
Caption: of unicorns
Caption: uh ming johansen if anyone doesn't know
Caption: ming then stick around you're
Caption: in for a treat um an amazing
Caption: advocate for our local tech community
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: let's go
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it
Caption: um i've got a memory like a sieve so the
Caption: marketing jump start i think yay got it
Caption: right
Caption: um if you don't know ming where have you
Caption: been
Caption: and
Caption: uh
Caption: as with myself i'm delighted ming's
Caption: presenting this room we're talking about
Caption: remote work and
Caption: how to manage
Caption: that
Caption: hands up burnout specialist right here
Caption: and
Caption: take it over me thank you hi everyone
Caption: i'm going to be standing here because i
Caption: have hair and the microphone doesn't
Caption: really
Caption: coordinate with that um
Caption: so first of all i wanted to thank the
Caption: sponsors honestly this event wouldn't be
Caption: able to
Caption: pay for lunch without the sponsors so
Caption: um so they have contributed a great
Caption: amount in order for us to be able to run
Caption: these cool events um so today i'm going
Caption: to be talking about how to be productive
Caption: when working remote
Caption: a little bit
Caption: about me
Caption: is that we have been working remote for
Caption: five years
Caption: uh i am the ceo of my own business i run
Caption: a company called marketing jumpstart
Caption: i've been running it for 12 years
Caption: i'm very tired
Caption: i also have a diagnosis of cptsd and
Caption: anxiety
Caption: i don't say that for anybody to feel
Caption: sorry for me or anything like that it's
Caption: actually more for
Caption: anybody in the room who might have their
Caption: own diagnosis and
Caption: needs to see the evidence in the room
Caption: i also talk in the media a lot you see
Caption: my face sometimes on the television
Caption: and on the radio
Caption: i think it's hilarious that they let me
Caption: um and also the biggest deal is that my
Caption: team is here for the first time ever
Caption: together
Caption: in the same room and the same state
Caption: can i get you guys to stand
Caption: up no they're not going to stand up
Caption: because they're shy introverts
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um so some notes about this talk
Caption: today what i'm going to go through is
Caption: the benefits of remote work
Caption: from the position of the employer and
Caption: the employee i'm going to talk about the
Caption: challenges of remote work and healthy
Caption: boundaries and communication and
Caption: distraction guilt
Caption: i'm also going to talk about adapting
Caption: the environment
Caption: and what that's meant for us
Caption: and i'm going to put some final notes
Caption: and lessons learned from the pandemic
Caption: so first off
Caption: time coverage
Caption: benefits for the employer um so two of
Caption: our team that's flown in from melbourne
Caption: and sydney
Caption: they are obviously two hours wait are
Caption: you ahead or behind i can't remember my
Caption: brain's not working
Caption: ahead cool
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: so on either side of the day we actually
Caption: have an extra four hours for our clients
Caption: so it means that we have a little bit
Caption: extra coverage
Caption: um more focused work happens when we're
Caption: working remote because we don't have
Caption: meetings on zoom every day
Caption: because we get fatigued
Caption: we figured that out really early on in
Caption: the pandemic
Caption: a larger pool of future employees
Caption: so i mentioned before i have cptsd
Caption: anxiety disorder
Caption: half of our team have ptsd executive
Caption: dysfunction adhd
Caption: all of the other acronyms um
Caption: and what it means is that we cater for a
Caption: higher level of neurodivergence
Caption: so having different types of work styles
Caption: means that we actually have different
Caption: values that we can add to the business
Caption: reduce this fixed cost for a business
Caption: owner is really important so obviously i
Caption: don't pay for an office
Caption: and for me that became really important
Caption: because i want to invest in my team
Caption: so as a business you could see this as
Caption: an opportunity to downsize
Caption: and reduce operating costs and invest
Caption: more in your people technology and for
Caption: me also training
Caption: benefits for the employee
Caption: less time in commute who loves commuting
Caption: not me
Caption: on average in western australia you
Caption: could spend 26.5 days a year
Caption: commuting to work
Caption: that's a lot of time
Caption: um for our team the fact that we don't
Caption: have to commute to work means that we
Caption: have that time back and we can spend it
Caption: on our hobbies
Caption: for which we have many
Caption: so hobbies like roller skating wool
Caption: spinning kira has three spinning wheels
Caption: yep
Caption: counting gardening food video games
Caption: photography music
Caption: one of our team who isn't here
Caption: unfortunately because he's unwell
Caption: is a musician
Caption: so things like nurturing support in a
Caption: business
Caption: the idea that someone being late for
Caption: work
Caption: in our business doesn't exist
Caption: one of the things that i say often to my
Caption: team is work to your bio rhythms
Caption: not to what the business needs
Caption: work to what you need
Caption: the reason why that change was made is
Caption: because that we tell ourselves a lot of
Caption: stories coming from corporate
Caption: work or previous works that we might
Caption: have worked how many of you have heard
Caption: things like leave your life at the door
Caption: couple people
Caption: so
Caption: more hobbies less time and compute
Caption: suited work environment so each of us
Caption: obviously work in our own homes
Caption: or at a cafe or at the beach
Caption: or in the middle of
Caption: a wonderful forest
Caption: so uniquely to each team member we all
Caption: get to work with our best colleagues as
Caption: well
Caption: our pets
Caption: so
Caption: some challenges for working remote
Caption: considering boundaries
Caption: now normally like christina mentioned it
Caption: this morning in her incredible keynote
Caption: about the idea that people just sort of
Caption: check in and go oh can you just have a
Caption: quick look at that for me
Caption: just yeah could could you just have a
Caption: look at this
Caption: and there's this constant disruption
Caption: that happens in an office
Caption: how that looks online
Caption: is 27 messages on
Caption: discord
Caption: or slack so relearning what that looks
Caption: like for you
Caption: when you don't have an open door policy
Caption: in your office
Caption: is then figuring out what your
Caption: boundaries look like
Caption: in your home
Caption: there's potential for scope slip
Caption: so because we're not talking to each
Caption: other face to face every day
Caption: our interactions are often online
Caption: and if things get complicated
Caption: text on a screen can make it worse
Caption: has anybody ever heard of
Caption: procrastinators
Caption: i'm trying to get it to trend um
Caption: requested shots when you're working from
Caption: home
Caption: it's really easy for you to get
Caption: distracted with all of the things that
Caption: you've got going on in your home
Caption: for me
Caption: i have been for the last six weeks
Caption: trying to film some videos for some
Caption: courses that we're doing
Caption: and instead of filming the videos what i
Caption: decided in my head was i would clean my
Caption: entire house
Caption: reorganize my storage room and paint a
Caption: wall
Caption: black
Caption: so
Caption: work life and your life can creep into
Caption: each other's spaces
Caption: one of the key things about that is be
Caption: gentle with yourself don't judge
Caption: yourself too harshly for that we all do
Caption: it
Caption: one of the other challenges that we have
Caption: is finding ways to close the distance
Caption: between the
Caption: team working in isolation can get really
Caption: hard and making sure that you've got
Caption: regular check-ins
Caption: and that having conversations that are
Caption: not just work conversations are actually
Caption: really valuable
Caption: so we've all been working together for
Caption: five years
Caption: and it took us for the pandemic to
Caption: happen for us to realize that we didn't
Caption: actually really know anything about each
Caption: other
Caption: because we are efficient we have all
Caption: these conversations about the work stuff
Caption: because that's what the meeting's for
Caption: so we don't have the water cooler
Caption: to have those oh what did you get up to
Caption: on the weekend those conversations are
Caption: actually really valuable to your
Caption: workplace
Caption: distraction guilt who's watched seven
Caption: seasons of frasier
Caption: three people well it's
Caption: suddenly feeling more guilty
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: so
Caption: there is studies to say that
Caption: people who work from home tend to work
Caption: more out of guilt
Caption: because they might have taken a little
Caption: bit longer for lunch
Caption: they might have streamed a few too many
Caption: episodes instead of actually doing work
Caption: again one of the rules in our business
Caption: is work to your own flow
Caption: so long as the job gets done
Caption: we have two deadlines
Caption: one is the real deadline for the client
Caption: the other is our internal deadline which
Caption: is two weeks prior
Caption: different communication styles
Caption: with everybody's different
Caption: neurodiversities
Caption: having awareness around the other
Caption: person's communication style can be
Caption: really challenging
Caption: most of the time we will communicate in
Caption: the ways that we prefer best
Caption: i am the worst culprit for this
Caption: i will often send things to my team at
Caption: rapid fire hey could you do this hey
Caption: could you do this hey i forgot about
Caption: this
Caption: i am working on it
Caption: work in progress
Caption: but remembering that other people
Caption: receive information differently and
Caption: trying to accommodate them recognize it
Caption: so adapting the environment
Caption: there's an importance of designated
Caption: workspace
Caption: kira very much has two different
Caption: workspaces so at the beginning of the
Caption: day she starts in her chair in her
Caption: office by the end of the day she's on
Caption: her couch
Caption: and
Caption: so a lot of that is about healthy
Caption: boundaries
Caption: for her mind her space and her
Caption: relationship with work
Caption: with me
Caption: this led to a very specific purchase
Caption: when i bought my house
Caption: i have an upstairs and a downstairs
Caption: upstairs is work downstairs is home
Caption: they do not cross
Caption: so once i step out of work literally and
Caption: figuratively
Caption: i am in my home space mode
Caption: and that's very important because one of
Caption: the people that i work with is also my
Caption: partner
Caption: activities for breaks so we have what we
Caption: call a circuit breaker event for me it's
Caption: going to do a food shop in the middle of
Caption: the day when nobody else is at the shops
Caption: but it's to get me outside of my house
Caption: and outside of outside of my environment
Caption: to make sure that my brain is not
Caption: getting too clouded
Caption: work time and home time
Caption: is your choice
Caption: if you stay late you're choosing that
Caption: and everything has to be a conscious
Caption: choice
Caption: nobody is putting a gun against your
Caption: head asking you to work late hours
Caption: certainly not in our business
Caption: one of the things that i say quite
Caption: regularly to the team is so long it is
Caption: as it is healthy
Caption: meal prep
Caption: is actually
Caption: way more important for
Caption: neurodiverse people
Caption: um well it's important for everyone but
Caption: for people who are neurodiverse
Caption: sometimes you can get really
Caption: super hyper fixated on things and then
Caption: you don't eat for two days
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: definitely me
Caption: kira is a recent convert to having
Caption: lunches she's very angry about it but
Caption: she loves it really
Caption: and she's eating lunches which are more
Caption: than a cereal box
Caption: it's not judgment i love you
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: some of the lessons that we learned from
Caption: the pandemic was fatigue
Caption: despite working from home prior to the
Caption: pandemic the challenges of the team were
Caption: shared by the team
Caption: even though we all had unique challenges
Caption: things like
Caption: covert fatigue and long covert
Caption: things that we were not expecting
Caption: these became things that we shared
Caption: collectively as a team
Caption: and it became really important for us to
Caption: share empathy with the rest of the team
Caption: managing mental spoons
Caption: there's some great blogs out there about
Caption: mental spoons and having how many spoons
Caption: you have for your day
Caption: some days you have less spoons because
Caption: you're borrowed from next week's spoons
Caption: currently we're working towards a
Caption: four-day week and we're doing this for
Caption: mental health reasons
Caption: we realize
Caption: that
Caption: the last two years have been hard
Caption: and it's four day work week with a five
Caption: day pay
Caption: to clarify
Caption: i'm not undercutting anybody
Caption: the business values are also imperative
Caption: they have been from day one for me
Caption: when i walked out of my previous
Caption: business it was because there was a
Caption: misalignment with values
Caption: and i swore that i would make a business
Caption: that was aligned with my values always
Caption: even as they evolve
Caption: the people in our business
Caption: are aligned with our values our clients
Caption: are aligned with our values
Caption: we have fired clients this year
Caption: for not being aligned with our values
Caption: i want to have a bit of a conversation
Caption: about
Caption: the word over achieving
Caption: say hello to my toxic
Caption: relationship it's with this word
Caption: we used to highlight it as really great
Caption: oh it's so great such an overachiever
Caption: with pride
Caption: and then our newest team member michael
Caption: who's from melbourne joined
Caption: and
Caption: i remember him saying to me oh i want to
Caption: be just like vern and just like derek
Caption: two of our highest overachievers in our
Caption: business
Caption: and i realized that our toxic
Caption: relationship with that word
Caption: sets the tone for anybody new coming
Caption: into our business
Caption: have a think about what you're setting
Caption: the tone for new people
Caption: so i've probably run under time because
Caption: i talk very quickly
Caption: yeah um
Caption: but my final notes is you might have
Caption: noticed that i've talked about work
Caption: environment and beliefs and structural
Caption: workplace and pitfalls the remote work
Caption: but ultimately the core thing is
Caption: actually
Caption: about productivity
Caption: is mental health and wellness and the
Caption: security of the team
Caption: when the pandemic kicked off one of the
Caption: decisions that i made
Caption: was to employ my team they were all
Caption: subcontractors at the time
Caption: and i employed them i gave them security
Caption: against every single piece of advice i
Caption: was given at the beginning of the
Caption: pandemic
Caption: every leader i spoke to everyone i spoke
Caption: to all of my peers
Caption: all of them
Caption: said to me i was crazy
Caption: said to me i was making foolish
Caption: decisions
Caption: said to me i was making a lot of risky
Caption: choices
Caption: ultimately without my team my business
Caption: is nothing
Caption: their wellness and security is the most
Caption: important thing
Caption: what it meant
Caption: was that two years into the pandemic
Caption: five out of the six of us bought houses
Caption: we all have security
Caption: with us having that security it also
Caption: meant that our clients have that
Caption: security we're not going anywhere
Caption: thanks for listening
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thank you ming for for sharing your
Caption: vulnerability i'm also adhd so i relate
Caption: to pretty much every slide there and
Caption: before i rattle on as an adhd person
Caption: could do are there any questions for me
Caption: down the back
Caption: i should point out um this past week
Caption: in terms of
Caption: yeah the toxic behaviors and
Caption: all of that i've so i'm the director of
Caption: media for d day this year so all of the
Caption: things with all of the branding that you
Caption: see in the conference i have had some
Caption: part in that um the
Caption: wonderful neon signs on the state main
Caption: stage is my responsibility um and i've
Caption: done a lot of work this week
Caption: specifically and worked like midnight
Caption: every day
Caption: plus running my business plus i also
Caption: decided in my infinite wisdom to do a
Caption: rebrand this week
Caption: completely forgot it's are you okay week
Caption: and
Caption: uh what was the other thing here
Caption: oh we did a photo shoot yeah and i flew
Caption: the team over
Caption: oh yeah no i definitely maxed out the
Caption: tabs in my brain
Caption: yes um thanks for the talk um i was
Caption: honoring you you mentioned you're
Caption: catching up for the first time yeah here
Caption: today
Caption: um i'm also you know doing remote work
Caption: for for many many years and i've
Caption: considered catching up at you know
Caption: regular times very valuable um
Caption: so um have you guys considered catching
Caption: up let's say every you know two three
Caption: months and at the place and work
Caption: together doing a vocation type of thing
Caption: so so two of our team work on the east
Caption: coast
Caption: yep
Caption: at the moment i can't afford to fly them
Caption: over every two weeks
Caption: um i've i would love that
Caption: i think two weeks would be a big ass
Caption: because everybody's got families and
Caption: life
Caption: stuff as well to work around um it is an
Caption: important thing that's been flagged as
Caption: something that we would like to do more
Caption: often absolutely
Caption: excuses like ddd perth it's a great
Caption: excuse for that
Caption: um
Caption: i don't know if that answers your
Caption: question yes
Caption: i do think it's important um if you have
Caption: a local team
Caption: catching up with them
Caption: um i catch up with all of my team once a
Caption: week online
Caption: and it is it is it has been enough for
Caption: the last five years
Caption: do you guys wanna
Caption: can i add something yeah i i would
Caption: recommend considering this to everyone
Caption: so um i was working in europe a lot and
Caption: um
Caption: i flew over from from another country to
Caption: meet the team every four to six weeks
Caption: because of this uh even before the
Caption: pandemic uh there was uh for myself very
Caption: important uh
Caption: you know to catch up and have this chit
Caption: chats and what what you've mentioned and
Caption: i can only you know recommend doing this
Caption: it's what you lose at the the costs you
Caption: lose basically for office you should
Caption: spend in yes kind of events that's um so
Caption: what so what we invested chose to invest
Caption: in was training at the time
Caption: um
Caption: and
Caption: i think one of the things i have always
Caption: encouraged from the team is that they
Caption: engage in community
Caption: that they find their own local community
Caption: and find their own peers
Caption: because we don't know what the pandemic
Caption: will look like in the future we might go
Caption: into another lockdown
Caption: the like
Caption: the concern i have is if we go into
Caption: another lockdown then how do we maintain
Caption: that how do we support that
Caption: i'd actually agree with that if your
Caption: team is remote at least find a tribe and
Caption: that's actually why i'm here at ddd
Caption: perth because i'm working remotely in a
Caption: team of one and i get to connect with
Caption: amazing people like ming who invited me
Caption: here um another question
Caption: um hi if you feel comfortable can you
Caption: expand a little bit on the toxic
Caption: relationship with overachieving
Caption: how people might recognize that in
Caption: themselves potentially
Caption: i don't know i think this week has been
Caption: a good example
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um
Caption: i think if you if so
Caption: specifically to people who work remote
Caption: you have on average two to four hours
Caption: that are actually productive
Caption: productive work
Caption: the rest of it is spinning wheels
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: and i think if you are pushing yourself
Caption: or drinking lots of red bull
Caption: caffeine intake's probably a good
Caption: indicator um
Caption: missing meals is another one
Caption: um
Caption: for me
Caption: i'm very lucky in the fact that i have a
Caption: great relationship where my partner is
Caption: got very healthy boundaries with work
Caption: and home life
Caption: and so a lot of that dictates my
Caption: relationship with that when i was single
Caption: i can guarantee you i would work 14
Caption: hours because sometimes
Caption: i don't have a perception of time
Caption: and i think
Caption: speaking to the neurodiversity side of
Caption: things
Caption: certainly this week i don't always know
Caption: what my max
Caption: output looks like
Caption: and it's taking
Caption: it's taken me probably five years to
Caption: figure out
Caption: you know maybe do too much
Caption: i think also being neuro-diverse there's
Caption: something called delay aversion so you
Caption: procrastinate and then you freak out and
Caption: you rush to the finish but you do it
Caption: successfully and that gives you a
Caption: dopamine reward and then you repeat the
Caption: behavior and it's self um
Caption: fulfilling
Caption: i'm getting better at it
Caption: i don't know if i've learned that lesson
Caption: yet because i'm still saying yes to lots
Caption: of things
Caption: i mean great
Caption: um it's not so much a question more on
Caption: observation i think like with the
Caption: toxic over-achieving uh linking
Caption: self-worth to achievements as well yeah
Caption: um so
Caption: not being satisfied with an outcome if
Caption: there's the perception of failure you
Caption: then look at yourself as a failure as
Caption: opposed to looking at the activity has
Caption: failed um
Caption: yeah so yeah that can be a big thing i
Caption: yeah so so just to add to that so with
Caption: the ptsd side of things a lot of my
Caption: internal dialogue is around total
Caption: catastrophic failure
Caption: um
Caption: and even this week like little things
Caption: have gone wrong this week
Caption: and my brain has gone oh my god
Caption: everybody's going to hate me it's going
Caption: to be the worst experience what's going
Caption: on i don't even know how to do this if
Caption: i'm going to show up and if i do my talk
Caption: and i'm not even ready and i haven't
Caption: even done my slides and that is
Caption: constantly in my brain
Caption: um
Caption: so yeah thank you thank you for pointing
Caption: that out
Caption: thanks bing for the talk um
Caption: you mentioned the four day week and i've
Caption: just on articles i've read the
Caption: rhetoric is around like
Caption: in the office you have that water cooler
Caption: time and a lot so really you can get
Caption: you know we can compress to a four day
Caption: week for our current workload for our
Caption: current five-day pay as what sounds like
Caption: an already efficient team as a business
Caption: owner if you're happy to share do you
Caption: have any ways you're working towards
Caption: that as a remote company to a four day
Caption: week
Caption: um
Caption: so some of it is around
Caption: figuring out what that work day looks
Caption: like that day off looks like so for some
Caption: of the team it's the monday they don't
Caption: they don't like they're more functional
Caption: if they have the saturday sunday monday
Caption: for the other half of the team it's the
Caption: friday saturday sunday
Caption: um
Caption: i at there's been conversations around
Caption: community engagement and whether or not
Caption: they wanted to use that time to engage
Caption: with their community
Caption: in terms of
Caption: cost management
Caption: chargeable for my clients is probably a
Caption: good start
Caption: because i don't charge enough um
Caption: yeah like the costs
Caption: and certainly employing people
Caption: and coming out of being a sole trader
Caption: into a company
Caption: this
Caption: my role has changed
Caption: my role in my own business has changed
Caption: from
Caption: lead gen to then being okay i'm like my
Caption: my days are staring at my bank account
Caption: and making sure that i can afford
Caption: to operate in the ways that we operate
Caption: i get zero joy from that
Caption: the joy i actually get from is is
Caption: working with my clients
Caption: so
Caption: uh
Caption: have we got a plan the plan is currently
Caption: we have some targets to hit for the
Caption: business so we can financially support
Caption: it
Caption: um and then when we start to implement
Caption: it we're going to do a trial just to get
Caption: our rhythms right um but you're quite
Caption: right like the the
Caption: the amount of work that we do as as
Caption: like we're a small team with a team of
Caption: six
Caption: the amount of work that we do is um
Caption: overwhelming
Caption: kira wrote a really great blog that's on
Caption: our website um which was something along
Caption: the what the ever-loving bleep have i
Caption: got have i gotten in myself into and i
Caption: think it was like a month into her job
Caption: a week in a week into the business
Caption: yeah um and she's now been in the
Caption: business for a year and a half i think
Caption: yeah um and so she sort of reflected on
Caption: all of the things that we do and she was
Caption: like oh i had no idea what you guys did
Caption: could i also add i think um what i've
Caption: learned about you is you like to help
Caption: people yeah and it's really hard to say
Caption: nice
Caption: and you have to retrain the way instead
Caption: of saying no about what help you can
Caption: give instead of actually taking it on
Caption: board and and
Caption: just getting it all done because you
Caption: achieve so much that you need to
Caption: actually temper that with um
Caption: prioritizing the right tasks i i
Caption: recently did a
Caption: money mindset training and one of the
Caption: things that came out of that was um i i
Caption: have a nurturer money mindset which
Caption: means that i want to help everyone
Caption: um except for myself and
Caption: um so i'd like i do have some boundaries
Caption: that i've put in place that i've learned
Caption: which is like with my community
Caption: engagement stuff limiting to 10 of my
Caption: time
Caption: um
Caption: but yeah so
Caption: starting to put boundaries in place and
Caption: stuff like that
Caption: so
Caption: with the gradual move towards remote
Caption: work for more and more businesses a lot
Caption: of companies seem to have trust issues
Caption: in their management staff trusting their
Caption: actual staff who do the processing the
Caption: actual work and do the output so do you
Caption: have any advice to help those people who
Caption: do have small businesses that are
Caption: looking at moving to remote for how to
Caption: develop that trust relationship as an
Caption: employer and also for the employees to
Caption: develop a trust relationship with them
Caption: because don't forget
Caption: if you don't trust your manager and
Caption: you're not in there every day
Caption: it's going to go horribly wrong so any
Caption: advice for businesses looking to do that
Caption: throw me a curveball sarah yeah
Caption: oh yeah thanks um
Caption: um
Caption: okay so a couple of things one is if
Caption: employers managers whoever are concerned
Caption: that their team are not doing their job
Caption: hire different people
Caption: hire people that you trust if you don't
Caption: hire people that you don't trust what
Caption: are you doing
Caption: and the other way around if you're
Caption: looking to find the right team to work
Caption: in actually figure that out first
Caption: because yeah it is all too common so
Caption: that kind of comes back to value
Caption: alignment
Caption: um
Caption: so things like for us
Caption: the question that i will always ask my
Caption: team when they're struggling with
Caption: something is how can i support you
Caption: it's never why didn't you do this
Caption: because that's always going to come back
Caption: with a point of aggression that's never
Caption: that's never going to be a helpful
Caption: question
Caption: um
Caption: but i've also managed people for over 20
Caption: years so
Caption: kyra
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: ming can obviously really answer that
Caption: from an employer's point of view but for
Caption: the people who work for her the way that
Caption: that pans out for us is that
Caption: i think the most important takeaway for
Caption: that for employers is don't dick over
Caption: your staff
Caption: because
Caption: i've been in really toxic work
Caption: environments and i now work for me and i
Caption: have been in situations where
Caption: they will say oh great come to us are
Caption: you okay is everything all right tell us
Caption: when you have problems and then we'll
Caption: use that as an excuse to screw you every
Caption: time
Caption: whereas
Caption: what i'm finding difficult to relax into
Caption: is the fact that i can actually have a
Caption: shitty day or have a problem or have
Caption: something and my boss isn't trying to
Caption: screw me
Caption: so i'll go to ming and she'll go okay
Caption: that's fine let's let's do something
Caption: else today let's find something else
Caption: that you can manage or let's put that on
Caption: the back burner and
Caption: you need to take a day
Caption: exactly
Caption: the amount of times i've said i'm sick
Caption: and just don't expect too much from me
Caption: today and she's like right you're going
Caption: to bed now i'm logging you off
Caption: it's just it's very different for an
Caption: employee i think to relax into that
Caption: space i also kind of want to point out
Caption: that if you are treating your employees
Caption: like their criminals
Caption: it makes them very kidnappable for a
Caption: better employer
Caption: case in point kira was kidnapped from
Caption: her last
Caption: employer
Caption: yep oh hi um i've got a question about
Caption: the different communication styles um
Caption: that's something that i've definitely
Caption: struggled with um since starting remote
Caption: work like uh
Caption: well
Caption: uh pandemic wise yeah um because i'm
Caption: more like i talk to speak and some
Caption: people
Caption: oh wait no sorry talk to think and some
Caption: people think to talk yeah and some
Caption: people think and then right yeah and i
Caption: really struggle with that so um do you
Caption: have any tips
Caption: um if so
Caption: first of all if you are having a
Caption: challenging conversation it's an
Caption: indicator that the other person is not
Caption: receiving you the right way
Caption: um and
Caption: ask
Caption: ask the other person how the best way is
Caption: for them to receive that information
Caption: um
Caption: is it's probably one of the best
Caption: pieces of advice i got when i was
Caption: learning to be a manager
Caption: was
Caption: just communicate with your manager
Caption: what's going on
Caption: and explain to them how you best a
Caption: receive information but then also try to
Caption: understand how they receive information
Caption: so we have team members who will much
Caption: prefer to have
Caption: a dot point list
Caption: and like the overview
Caption: and then there will be team members who
Caption: want every they all the details they
Caption: want all the details and the minutia
Caption: then there's me who rolls in and is a
Caption: verbal communicator and
Caption: doesn't like writing emails um and so i
Caption: have to force myself
Caption: to slow down
Caption: and actually find space to write that
Caption: stuff like
Caption: to write out all of that
Caption: um information things like building pro
Caption: so i'm very good at building processes
Caption: from
Caption: from a thing that i've done if so long
Caption: as i've done it so if i can do an action
Caption: or create something i can then create
Caption: the user guide for it
Caption: um and that has sort of become the
Caption: really good transition point for us
Caption: right now in our business where we're
Caption: building out
Caption: like standard operating procedures and
Caption: stuff like that
Caption: and then we're reviewing it regularly
Caption: making sure that it's up to date and
Caption: it's current and especially in the
Caption: industry that we work in the technology
Caption: is constantly changing
Caption: um so we're about to break for lunch and
Caption: so that ming doesn't have to rely on
Caption: cereal for most of the meals throughout
Caption: this event can we have one more round of
Caption: applause for ming thanks so much guys
Caption: thank you for coming
Caption: thank you very much thanks thanks for
Caption: coordinating the room joe
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puzzles
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: yes
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are gonna love it i
Caption: got a real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am
Caption: cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: being beret uh as you can tell by the
Caption: accent i am french very very permanent
Caption: accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow i also got a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top level is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your
Caption: carrier you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: moq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselmans
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep and i
Caption: think our customers are going to love it
Caption: i got a real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be now is
Caption: the time to do big things together now
Caption: is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and
Caption: i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me jester because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: uh
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: being the ray
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of um sparks and enjoy and so yeah
Caption: so being better it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me
Caption: so i'm better than yesterday and i'll be
Caption: better tomorrow but i also got a lot of
Caption: training opportunities and planning
Caption: because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do and who always want
Caption: to want to learn and get better um i
Caption: think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top level is the best of the best and
Caption: for me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your career
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join scott handsome
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: sticky
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero up what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: my dream come true i've always wanted to
Caption: join handsome
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all for more
Caption: than 30 years people have trusted us to
Caption: turn ambitious projects into meaningful
Caption: outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: being the ray
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very permanent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with um hello kitty
Caption: riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of um sparks and enjoy and so yeah
Caption: so being there it is my name is kong i'm
Caption: a consultant here at planet and it's
Caption: when people ask me how to pronounce my
Caption: name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for target we
Caption: always try to go a little bit further
Caption: and we try to inspire each other by
Caption: learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better um i think that's really
Caption: important and i think it's going to be a
Caption: driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your carrier
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your carrier you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mo q digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: canada needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer
Caption: i hear you so let's use off zero off
Caption: what now off zero it's an identity
Caption: platform fast easy logins just what the
Caption: boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: first
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test engineer
Caption: my call sign is special case you might
Caption: be familiar with it you see it in cereal
Caption: boxes it's my call sign because i like
Caption: eating i eat a lot when people see me
Caption: they always see me eating and they
Caption: always ask me carol why are you eating
Caption: and i think that just when they see when
Caption: they see the cereal box they say okay
Caption: that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshini i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me gesture because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge math nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the direct completely makes sense as
Caption: for the being no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a big background with hello kitty riding
Caption: a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of um sparks and enjoy and so yeah
Caption: so being there it is my name is kong i'm
Caption: a consultant here at planet and it's
Caption: when people ask me how to pronounce my
Caption: name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong
Caption: work to inspire is very something that
Caption: we live by i believe we definitely see
Caption: how much passion we are for quality and
Caption: how much we want to convey this as a
Caption: client we don't just go for target we
Caption: always try to go a little bit further
Caption: and we try to inspire each other by
Caption: learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also get a lot of training opportunities
Caption: on planet because there's a vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to just
Caption: accelerate your career growth top-notch
Caption: testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to want to learn and
Caption: get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: if you want to grow up in your career
Caption: you are at the right place because we
Caption: have got all the training materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything
Caption: in a compact pack that's what planet is
Caption: for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: so
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best friend is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: bye
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerd's nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott hanselman's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: please
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop that's really
Caption: distracting
Caption: we did it it's done already yep i think
Caption: our customers are gonna love it i got a
Caption: real app now folks
Caption: [Music]
Caption: you know what i want a bodyguard
Caption: hey we got a customer
Caption: cool app
Caption: my name's steven
Caption: what's up steven
Caption: we can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: right
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Music]
Caption: uh
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our poses
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: ambition is a fearless hunger for
Caption: success it drives us to challenge the
Caption: way things are to pursue what seems
Caption: insurmountable to keep going when others
Caption: would stop ambition is how a global
Caption: manufacturer is using ai to empower
Caption: employees with disabilities ambition is
Caption: how a company managed an overnight
Caption: transition to remote work for 100 000
Caption: teammates ambition is how a children's
Caption: hospital built an app to reduce stress
Caption: for families ambition is how a law firm
Caption: rallied against a malware attack to
Caption: reclaim control and prevent a
Caption: devastating breach of client confidence
Caption: at insight we know the power of ambition
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we've grown from a small technology
Caption: provider founded by two young brothers
Caption: to a fortune 500 company offering i.t
Caption: services and solutions for all
Caption: for more than 30 years people have
Caption: trusted us to turn ambitious projects
Caption: into meaningful outcomes
Caption: what will your ambitious story be
Caption: now is the time to do big things
Caption: together now is the time to be ambitious
Caption: [Music]
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: my name is carol i'm a test
Caption: engineer my call sign is special case
Caption: you might be familiar with it you see it
Caption: in cereal boxes it's my call sign
Caption: because i like eating i eat a lot when
Caption: people see me they always see me eating
Caption: and they always ask me carol why are you
Caption: eating and i think that just when they
Caption: see when they see the cereal box they
Caption: say okay that's carol
Caption: hi i'm joshni i'm a test engineer they
Caption: call me jester because i always have a
Caption: smile on my face whatever situation i'm
Caption: in
Caption: my name is jaden i'm an automation
Caption: engineer here at planet my call sign is
Caption: digit because i'm a huge huge maths nerd
Caption: it is it is it is my primary major um
Caption: but i often get called out
Caption: on how i never never ever ever stop
Caption: talking about maths
Caption: i just love maths
Caption: i am cassandra i am a test automation
Caption: especially
Caption: pink beret
Caption: as you can tell by the accent i am
Caption: french very very prominent accent
Caption: so the beret completely makes sense as
Caption: for the pink no matter the client no
Caption: matter where i was working it always was
Caption: a pink background with
Caption: hello kitty riding a unicorn
Caption: it does not reflect who i am outside
Caption: clearly but i think it brings a little
Caption: bit of
Caption: sparks and enjoy and so yeah so being
Caption: very it is
Caption: my name is kong i'm a consultant here at
Caption: planet and it's when people ask me how
Caption: to pronounce my name i always say
Caption: i'm not the king but the kong
Caption: but after joining planet
Caption: i am the king and i'm the kong work to
Caption: inspire is very something that we live
Caption: by i believe we definitely see how much
Caption: passion we are for quality and how much
Caption: we want to convey this as a client we
Caption: don't just go for
Caption: target we always try to go a little bit
Caption: further and we try to inspire each other
Caption: by learning new skills having new
Caption: challenges and taking them and i think
Caption: it's very inspiring we better build
Caption: better personally i always try to be
Caption: better than yesterday
Caption: that's always been me so i'm better than
Caption: yesterday and i'll be better tomorrow i
Caption: also got a lot of training opportunities
Caption: and planning because there's a fast vast
Caption: library of training courses available
Caption: that i can just access anytime before i
Caption: join planet like when you want to learn
Caption: something google first right and then
Caption: when you google something you always
Caption: have to pay for something and that's not
Caption: that's not what i want to do so it's
Caption: really it's really good that planet
Caption: offers these free courses for me and i
Caption: don't have to feel pressured about
Caption: buying something just so i can improve
Caption: my skills and use them for work
Caption: planet always encourages learning and
Caption: learning is a good way to
Caption: just accelerate your career growth
Caption: top-notch testing is um it's awesome
Caption: it's it's
Caption: really cool to be around people who are
Caption: so passionate so driven
Caption: to do what they do
Caption: and who always want to
Caption: want to learn and get better
Caption: i think that's really important and i
Caption: think it's going to be a driving factor
Caption: going forward in in the it industry in
Caption: general
Caption: top one is the best of the best and for
Caption: me it's
Caption: uh if you want to grow up in your
Caption: carrier you are at the right place
Caption: because we have got all the training
Caption: materials
Caption: right people and right opportunities
Caption: yeah whatever you need to progress in
Caption: your career you have got everything in
Caption: here
Caption: to boost your experience and boost your
Caption: personality everything in a compact pack
Caption: that's what planet is for me
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: mark where are you mark open you turn
Caption: your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our pockets
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: tell me the best thing that's happened
Caption: while i was gone i made your dad ate
Caption: healthy like you said he even tried the
Caption: broccoli eat it
Caption: then i helped him make his work much
Caption: better
Caption: and we found the perfect outfit to wear
Caption: to my party
Caption: but i really needed to wind down before
Caption: bed so i turned my hand into a starfish
Caption: my best thing is you being back
Caption: by applying market leading technology
Caption: solutions through our lifecycle services
Caption: we help clients realize business
Caption: outcomes through our advice integration
Caption: and operational services
Caption: mlq digital helps clients to fully
Caption: understand their it needs adopt the
Caption: right solution and provide ongoing
Caption: support to maximize their investment
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: good
Caption: uh
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on um
Caption: okay you can you can see me
Caption: yeah
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: [Music]
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our puzzles
Caption: this is like my dream come true i've
Caption: always wanted to join scott held
Caption: someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: please
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh
Caption: the app is almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something uh it's 3 15 and no
Caption: one's here to introduce me so i'm just
Caption: gonna introduce myself because i wanna
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: you guys are such an easy to please
Caption: audience can i just leave now
Caption: um i want to get you out of here on time
Caption: well as much on time as i can
Caption: um there's a pronunciation my name is
Caption: aish
Caption: um i am so ice works in and around
Caption: technology projects she won some awards
Caption: a few years ago but the important thing
Caption: is she loves figuring out how diverse
Caption: teams work at their best
Caption: so now i'm going to switch the first
Caption: person
Caption: if you haven't already there's a qr code
Caption: up on here for you to scan it basically
Caption: gives you access to the slides and the
Caption: closed captions on your device uh emotes
Caption: as well a little bit like microsoft
Caption: teams and i'm going to want a lot of
Caption: that because i need validation and this
Caption: is nice for me
Caption: but it also means that at the end of the
Caption: session you'll have an opportunity to
Caption: give me feedback it's completely
Caption: anonymous
Caption: and it comes straight into my inbox at
Caption: the very end of the session
Caption: and i would really love to hear from you
Caption: so for people um in person and online
Caption: hopefully you can see this qr code it'll
Caption: be on the next slide as well hi mom and
Caption: dad they're on the youtube live
Caption: hello and welcome my name is aish
Caption: how lucky are we to live and work on
Caption: abuja it's incredible that we get to be
Caption: here in face to face in a conference
Caption: after such a long time
Caption: and all the wonderful conversations that
Caption: we've had today right in the heart of
Caption: perth and burulu
Caption: and i just want to express my gratitude
Caption: to all the traditional custodians of
Caption: this beautiful land for continuing to
Caption: share their culture and their traditions
Caption: with us
Caption: thank you all if your logo is up on here
Caption: as well
Caption: um without you and your support as
Caption: sponsors we would not be here today um
Caption: thanks for giving emerging speakers like
Caption: me an opportunity to get the hang of
Caption: this thing
Caption: let's get into the show
Caption: now i
Caption: i know you all voted for the swear word
Caption: in the title but thanks anyway
Caption: while you get comfortable with
Caption: powerpoint live let me tell you a little
Caption: bit about me that's myself and donna
Caption: boyd up here last year talking about
Caption: product ownership it was our first ever
Caption: conference talk
Caption: and i'm clearly a glutton for punishment
Caption: so i'm back at it
Caption: i am an idealist
Caption: i never really outgrew that naive little
Caption: girl who wants to adopt all the dogs in
Caption: the shelter save the whales end world
Caption: hunger join the united nations
Caption: but i did realize that the best way for
Caption: me to make change is to focus in on the
Caption: things that i'm good at
Caption: the things that i like doing the things
Caption: the world needs and things i can get
Caption: paid for
Caption: and that is focusing in on that
Caption: intersection between business technology
Caption: and social impact
Caption: it's because of that i'm incredibly
Caption: passionate about diversity and inclusion
Caption: i mean how can i not be
Caption: but it's about leveraging diversity and
Caption: inclusion to enable and support
Caption: sustainable high-performing teams
Caption: and that's exactly what we're going to
Caption: talk about today
Caption: to ur is human
Caption: to learn divine
Caption: hindsight's always 20 20. if only we had
Caption: that in 2020.
Caption: it's really difficult to take a moment
Caption: to pause and reflect
Caption: on
Caption: difficult times particularly when you're
Caption: right in the middle of it now i had a
Caption: lot of really great ideas on how to
Caption: actually run this session you know i had
Caption: this vision that i was live facilitating
Caption: and you were like screaming your
Caption: frustrations out at me and some of the
Caption: worst projects that you've ever been a
Caption: part of but i wasn't sure that i'd be
Caption: able to get you angry and then calm
Caption: again in 20 minutes so you don't go
Caption: outside picking fights with people
Caption: but also you're here to listen and to
Caption: learn not to work
Caption: so i had that session with smaller
Caption: groups of people who already had a high
Caption: level of psychological safety
Caption: and these are the four things that we
Caption: came up with the four top challenges
Caption: that we're going to unpack today one by
Caption: one
Caption: it's not my job get your remotes hands
Caption: up eye rolls groans if you've heard this
Caption: before
Caption: well if it's not your job whose job is
Caption: it then if you're hearing this in your
Caption: retros or in your projects towards the
Caption: end of the reporting cycle or whatever
Caption: it might be
Caption: it basically means that there have been
Caption: assumptions that have gone wrong but
Caption: they've been proven to be wrong
Caption: someone has assumed that this isn't part
Caption: of their role and you have assumed that
Caption: it is
Caption: you cannot assume
Caption: that people understand what their role
Caption: is
Caption: you cannot assume that people's
Caption: interpretation of their role is the same
Caption: as yours
Caption: this is especially true for multi-vendor
Caption: teams and teams where you have a mix of
Caption: operational project and product people
Caption: we each have a different lens that we
Caption: bring into what our role actually means
Caption: and what it means to work and how they
Caption: interact with each other
Caption: and it's incredibly important that we
Caption: actually
Caption: bring ourselves together to get that
Caption: common understanding that common clarity
Caption: on how we'll work together today
Caption: what you need to do is first steps do we
Caption: all actually agree on what our problem
Caption: is
Caption: do we understand what we're trying to
Caption: solve why are we even here in the first
Caption: place
Caption: when you have a clarity on that then you
Caption: can do your visioning what's that
Caption: desired outcome where are we heading to
Caption: what do we want to be
Caption: in three six months years time what are
Caption: we trying to get to
Caption: from there
Caption: you have to understand what are the
Caption: things that you actually need to do
Caption: forget your project methodology for a
Caption: moment but what do you actually need to
Caption: get done
Caption: what's your value chain
Caption: that's going to get you to where you
Caption: want to go
Caption: when you have that value chain
Caption: understood and broken down as much as
Caption: you possibly can to get your best
Caption: estimates from here you can have a look
Caption: around and think and talk about the kind
Caption: of project methodology you think is
Caption: going to suit your project the best
Caption: what roles are available to you and then
Caption: you can agree and assign those roles and
Caption: responsibilities
Caption: what's within your remit
Caption: today
Caption: now you might be talking to me and like
Caption: might be thinking in your head we've
Caption: done this and there's still things that
Caption: come up that we don't know who it
Caption: belongs to
Caption: or maybe you're trying you're thinking
Caption: about well the product that we're
Caption: working on doesn't actually have a very
Caption: clearly defined outcome
Caption: well it's true we don't have a crystal
Caption: ball and we don't
Caption: know always what's going to come up and
Caption: potentially derail us on our journey to
Caption: our end vision or our end goal
Caption: this is where you come together as a
Caption: team and you actually talk about the
Caption: roles that are available to you and your
Caption: team what are your experiences in
Caption: previous projects in previous
Caption: organizations how have you worked with a
Caption: project sponsor previously
Caption: what do you expect your tester to do
Caption: are there some roles or some
Caption: responsibilities i should say that your
Caption: change manager would traditionally be
Caption: responsible for but in this particular
Caption: project it makes more sense for your ba
Caption: to do that
Caption: what's within your remit today
Caption: what's the social contract that you're
Caption: forming
Caption: someone clearly did not think it was
Caption: their role to clear the path before
Caption: painting and i don't think it led to a
Caption: remarkable outcome
Caption: in a game of he said she said you're
Caption: going to want to keep your receipts i
Caption: don't care how i just make sure that you
Caption: do
Caption: number two
Caption: we don't do things that way have you
Caption: heard this before you've come in new to
Caption: the team and you've tried to like
Caption: introduce a new way of working sorry
Caption: mate you must be a bit new here we don't
Caption: really do things that way things have
Caption: been working fine until you came along
Caption: there's not enough angry emojis in there
Caption: but i love it
Caption: it can be pretty tricky to balance
Caption: chaos and order
Caption: particularly when you're trying to
Caption: manage the different people's
Caption: expectations and their different comfort
Caption: levels along with the type of project
Caption: methodology that's going to suit the
Caption: organization that you're delivering to
Caption: where your customers are comfortable
Caption: with what your team's personalities are
Caption: and so on and so forth
Caption: often you'll find people gravitating
Caption: towards process and
Caption: um procedures in more like governance
Caption: heavy and regulation and heavy
Caption: environments or when people are
Caption: particularly uncomfortable with chaos
Caption: as consultants we're often asked to
Caption: bring a best practice approach to
Caption: executing work and it's fantastic for us
Caption: to be able to lean on our experiences
Caption: on what's worked really well before
Caption: other similar companies or the similar
Caption: size projects
Caption: but the thing about software development
Caption: is the sheer number of variables means
Caption: that
Caption: well there's no real silver bullet to
Caption: delivering an outcome
Caption: there's so many things that you need to
Caption: consider when deciding on what's the
Caption: best approach and technique that you can
Caption: take
Caption: what are the project funding cycles and
Caption: how does your team report to them
Caption: what kind of
Caption: legal and regulatory bodies
Caption: do you sit under there's so much that
Caption: you have to consider here
Caption: there's another talk about best fit and
Caption: best practice that i think happened
Caption: earlier today and i would love to catch
Caption: that online and i highly highly
Caption: recommend that you do too if you weren't
Caption: able to get to it because there are so
Caption: many different ways
Caption: to organize yourselves and execute work
Caption: and someone might organize themselves in
Caption: a different way to you
Caption: i am talking about both the
Caption: opportunities when you're trying to
Caption: introduce a new step in a process or
Caption: when you're actually trying to take
Caption: something out
Caption: i can't count the number of times that
Caption: someone's come to me with an idea to
Caption: potentially or to my team let's organize
Caption: the backlog a little bit differently
Caption: or let's add a little bit more structure
Caption: to sprint planning and it's always been
Caption: met with resistance to change
Caption: and that's the key thing about this
Caption: particular topic
Caption: as humans we are naturally resistant to
Caption: change there's a lot of fear there's a
Caption: lot of not being able to learn something
Caption: from scratch or not performing well
Caption: enough while you are learning
Caption: but in this particular instance as well
Caption: there could be some level of insecurity
Caption: about you know why isn't the way that
Caption: we've been working good enough
Caption: what's wrong with it we've gotten here
Caption: so i'm all this way so far
Caption: change only happens
Caption: when the pain of staying the same is
Caption: greater than the pain of change
Caption: and the best thing to do in this
Caption: scenario is to do something with and
Caption: through someone rather than to them
Caption: bring your folks together and actually
Caption: have that frank discussion about
Caption: what are the gaps that you're seeing
Caption: what are the blockers and the
Caption: bottlenecks that you want to address
Caption: chances are others are potentially
Caption: feeling it too but maybe they're too
Caption: nervous to speak up or maybe they're too
Caption: focused on the doing to be able to pause
Caption: and reflect on how they're doing
Caption: when you have people collaborating
Caption: together on the solution it actually
Caption: you're actually
Caption: empowering people to have ownership of
Caption: the changes that you're trying to get
Caption: them to adapt to
Caption: ask the question though is this actually
Caption: going to help or hinder us this extra
Caption: step that we're going to put in before
Caption: we make a decision is that going to lead
Caption: to better decisions
Caption: are there other ways that we can get the
Caption: same outcome
Caption: even if it's not from a playbook or a
Caption: scrum guide
Caption: the main thing to remember though is to
Caption: experiment
Caption: give people a refund policy give them a
Caption: bit of a way out basically
Caption: um
Caption: test the waters give something a red hot
Caption: go before coming together as a team to
Caption: evaluate is this actually working for us
Caption: maybe it's uncovered something else that
Caption: we'd rather focus on
Caption: building a culture of experimentation
Caption: into your team early on
Caption: makes it so much easier for you to add
Caption: incremental change into your into the
Caption: way that your team works more often
Caption: because people are going to be
Caption: comfortable and familiar that change is
Caption: only going to stick when it's actually
Caption: working for you
Caption: but experimentation also also allows you
Caption: and your team to scale as your product
Caption: matures
Caption: we didn't get anything done we didn't
Caption: finish our sprints because you know they
Caption: just kept changing their minds we can't
Caption: seem to get anything right here
Caption: yeah
Caption: if you're hearing this let's talk about
Caption: it
Caption: scope creep changing requirements
Caption: acrobatic backflipping clients it's a
Caption: circus out there
Caption: the agile manifesto was essentially
Caption: borne out of many of the challenges that
Caption: we've discussed today
Caption: but this is my favorite way of
Caption: explaining why socializing your product
Caption: early and often is the best way to avoid
Caption: surprises
Caption: you've probably experienced this where
Caption: your ba or your product owner or your
Caption: customer themselves have spoken to you
Caption: about this is what we want build it
Caption: we've gone and done the thing showed it
Caption: to them
Caption: [Music]
Caption: the thing about changing requirements is
Caption: though or changing your mind like
Caption: everything in moderation like i said
Caption: before we don't have a crystal ball and
Caption: we don't expect everyone's going to get
Caption: everything right the first time
Caption: this is why feedback loops are so
Caption: important early and often to make sure
Caption: that you'll be able to catch this
Caption: sooner rather than later and be able to
Caption: have that conversation and go on the
Caption: journey with your client
Caption: we want to create sustainable solutions
Caption: and happy customers
Caption: and regular feedback is the best way to
Caption: do that
Caption: there's no sound but that's the caption
Caption: at the end of the day
Caption: you can spend all the time in the world
Caption: understanding your customer spending
Caption: time with them showcasing your product
Caption: regularly and early
Caption: you can understand their preferences and
Caption: their style and still they might keep
Caption: changing their minds
Caption: there could be a few underlying reasons
Caption: for this that they might not be upfront
Caption: about with you
Caption: maybe there's some funding issues that
Caption: they're not at liberty to discuss with
Caption: you
Caption: or maybe they're just not the right
Caption: people to actually make a decision at
Caption: the end of it
Caption: there's still a few things if you feel
Caption: like you have the ability to influence
Caption: but you can still do here
Caption: help them build empathy for what it
Caption: costs you
Caption: to deal with their change of mind
Caption: set your boundaries firmly but gently
Caption: but explain why
Caption: bring them on the journey with you and
Caption: don't assume
Caption: that they know what it costs you
Caption: there's a one of my favorite things to
Caption: do is the power of contrast
Caption: i love presenting one good option that i
Caption: want them to choose and then another
Caption: option that's technically feasible but
Caption: otherwise potentially not quite suitable
Caption: it's much easier to be able to see
Caption: and poke holes in something when you can
Caption: actually see it
Caption: presenting multiple options is also a
Caption: fantastic way to
Caption: demonstrate the evolution of a product
Caption: vision and the ideas that all of you
Caption: have had whether it be from a user's
Caption: point of view
Caption: or from a technical feasibility point of
Caption: view
Caption: i've definitely been in scenarios when
Caption: we've been on a bit of a journey on what
Caption: that product should be doing and we've
Caption: got customers who
Caption: tend to sort of revert to thinking that
Caption: they had maybe three months ago six
Caption: months ago why can't we do it that way
Caption: again i can't remember everyone's got a
Caption: lot going on there's probably lots of
Caption: projects that they're all spread across
Caption: out on
Caption: but presenting multiple options and
Caption: being able to see that contrast can
Caption: vividly
Caption: show and demonstrate the difference
Caption: between where we are now where we
Caption: started from and clearly explaining why
Caption: what is the evolution of our thought
Caption: process here
Caption: don't forget to reinforce any further
Caption: benefits of
Caption: the
Caption: current state of what you've built
Caption: and let them know about ongoing support
Caption: and feedback opportunities as well
Caption: anything you can do to ease a little bit
Caption: of that fear of commitment
Caption: easier said than done for most
Caption: but if you don't respect your own time
Caption: and your own sanity
Caption: other people won't either
Caption: finally
Caption: it's retro time
Caption: you're talking about what you want to
Caption: keep doing stop doing start doing
Caption: and your team are all voting on how well
Caption: the sprint went
Caption: you're getting fours and fives out of
Caption: five
Caption: but maybe you didn't actually finish
Caption: your stories maybe some blockers weren't
Caption: escalated
Caption: and dependencies on other teams were
Caption: left really really late
Caption: now i am specifically talking about
Caption: those sprints where
Caption: things weren't in tip-top shape but your
Caption: team are quite close-knit
Caption: and feeling a bit self-congratulatory or
Caption: maybe they're ignoring the elephants in
Caption: the room
Caption: or maybe they're actually voting more on
Caption: how each of you as individuals dealt
Caption: with the challenges that your team faced
Caption: rather than how the sprint actually went
Caption: retrospectives are an opportunity
Caption: to come together as a team and evaluate
Caption: how people process and tools are coming
Caption: together
Caption: to help you and your team deliver it's
Caption: not about airing dirty laundry and we're
Caption: not asking for people to come out and
Caption: point fingers and start fights or
Caption: anything like that
Caption: it is about balance and
Caption: if you have a team that seems to be
Caption: unwilling to speak about the real issues
Caption: that are impacting delivery it could be
Caption: a sign that they're lacking
Caption: psychological safety
Caption: you don't need harvard business review
Caption: to tell you that psychological safety is
Caption: the cornerstone of high performing and
Caption: multi-disciplinary teams teams that i'm
Caption: sure each of us working day in day out
Caption: but it also
Caption: means that cognitive diversity diversity
Caption: of thought is better leveraged when
Caption: people are comfortable with each other
Caption: and familiar with alternative points of
Caption: view
Caption: building psychological safety in your
Caption: team is hard work it takes time and
Caption: energy but it is well worth it
Caption: you can start by encouraging your team
Caption: to understand themselves assess
Caption: themselves think about how they like to
Caption: think work and behave
Caption: doing this helps you uncover any
Caption: cognitive biases that you might have
Caption: that could potentially be contributing
Caption: to the problem or the culture that you
Caption: might have
Caption: that you're trying to tackle
Caption: understanding how you like to respond to
Caption: change or how you respond to conflict
Caption: can almost give you
Caption: a moment to basically decide how you're
Caption: going to respond to some stimulus
Caption: but simple things like taking an
Caption: interest in people's lives and actively
Caption: soliciting questions from them giving
Caption: them multiple channels to give feedback
Caption: and to communicate depending on their
Caption: personality types these are things that
Caption: you can do no matter your position on
Caption: the team formal leadership or not
Caption: and if you do have a culture of fear
Caption: that's stopping people from sharing
Caption: ideas the moments that somebody actually
Caption: does
Caption: you need to be ready with a positive
Caption: response
Caption: if you are on a formal leadership team
Caption: you have it is critical though that you
Caption: are clear and precise with your
Caption: expectations because this is how you
Caption: build trust and build reliability within
Caption: your team
Caption: if you make mistakes
Caption: own up to them if there are changes
Caption: explain them
Caption: be more human be divine be vulnerable
Caption: you cannot underestimate the influence
Caption: that you have on team dynamics no matter
Caption: your position on the team culture is top
Caption: down
Caption: but
Caption: the individual behaviors basically
Caption: explain to ourselves and to each other
Caption: what
Caption: what we're willing to accept from our
Caption: colleagues and from ourselves
Caption: and people are always responsible
Caption: responsive
Caption: to purposeful and courageous
Caption: vulnerability
Caption: at the end of the day retrospectives are
Caption: about getting a team that's so focused
Caption: on the next big thing the next sprint to
Caption: actually pause and reflect on what's
Caption: just been
Caption: they're a great way to introduce
Caption: incremental change but sometimes complex
Caption: problems can come up as well
Caption: complex problems are often the sign of a
Caption: team that has uh that's letting
Caption: something fester because they don't feel
Caption: comfortable talking about it until
Caption: eventually it explodes
Caption: every single framework to organize
Caption: people works capitalism communism the
Caption: free market a donut economy that is
Caption: until
Caption: people get involved
Caption: the things that make us different
Caption: make things so complicated
Caption: but the things that make us different
Caption: can make us even stronger if it's
Caption: harnessed appropriately
Caption: each of us are a product of our
Caption: experiences we've all experienced life
Caption: and work so differently and we bring
Caption: that into every single interaction that
Caption: we ever have
Caption: the way we respond to change the way we
Caption: set boundaries or don't the way we
Caption: respond to conflict
Caption: each of these can be a challenge turned
Caption: into an opportunity
Caption: if we just take a little bit of time out
Caption: of our days to pause and reflect on
Caption: what's just been
Caption: who we are now and where we want to go
Caption: and if we do this together as a team we
Caption: can make sure that our teams are humming
Caption: thanks ddd sponsors committee all of you
Caption: for coming along to my talk i really
Caption: appreciate it big shout out to jenny
Caption: one's agile and product community as
Caption: well for being my guinea pigs and my
Caption: brainstorms brains trust please connect
Caption: with me let's have a chat if you agree
Caption: or disagree about anything i would love
Caption: to hear from you and the feedback on
Caption: your devices as well
Caption: that's all folks
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: i mean i don't think we have time for
Caption: questions but i'll take them i don't
Caption: mind i don't know where to be
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: any questions now
Caption: i'm happy to anyone hands up anyone
Caption: bueller
Caption: i'm not gonna scare you
Caption: it's gonna shoot you
Caption: hello
Caption: um and you talked about a lot about
Caption: setting boundaries and i think a lot of
Caption: us have experience with dealing with
Caption: some quite difficult stakeholders do you
Caption: have any i guess general tips on how
Caption: people can approach conversations i
Caption: guess around setting boundaries
Caption: right
Caption: look when you're dealing with difficult
Caption: stakeholders sometimes the best thing to
Caption: do is to shield yourself and your team
Caption: as much as possible from them but
Caption: sometimes you know we're in a position
Caption: where we are the shield and that's going
Caption: to be tricky and there's a lot of things
Caption: that you'll have to balance your own
Caption: mental health your own capacity and
Caption: capability to deal with conflict in that
Caption: scenario we are all human and you cannot
Caption: be expected to deal in with hostile in
Caption: um
Caption: circumstances day in day out
Caption: there's a lot of things that you can do
Caption: to mentally prepare yourself for a
Caption: difficult conversation
Caption: doing whatever works for you for
Caption: mindfulness for taking a walk clearing
Caption: your mind preparing what you're going to
Caption: say coming in with notes even bringing
Caption: someone as a support person in with you
Caption: those are the kind of things that i
Caption: would do before
Caption: having knowing that i'm about to have a
Caption: difficult conversation with someone and
Caption: also don't forget
Caption: to expect that no matter what happens
Caption: well the word's not going to crash
Caption: you're not going to die like the worst
Caption: thing that's going to happen is you know
Caption: maybe you just don't like each other
Caption: after a while that's okay you're gonna
Caption: be fine you're gonna survive whatever
Caption: 30 minute conversation you've got in
Caption: your calendar you still have the rest of
Caption: the day to look forward to
Caption: i think you make a really good point
Caption: about having someone who can advocate
Caption: for you and and having that person
Caption: alongside you early
Caption: lived experience of exactly
Caption: this issue um
Caption: and knowing that you're
Caption: uh you're allowed to take a breath i
Caption: was at a pitch night at the museum i
Caption: don't know if anyone else was there the
Caption: innovation night too and uh host talked
Caption: about his stutter and he said you might
Caption: see me do this and i might be having
Caption: this way and that's because of this and
Caption: he opened the conversation for anyone
Caption: else to share what's going on for them
Caption: so
Caption: advocating for each other and actually
Caption: knowing that we're all human and we'll
Caption: make mistakes and we can all actually um
Caption: just collaborate beautiful thank you
Caption: thank you so much any other questions
Caption: i know half the people in this room so
Caption: it's fine
Caption: thanks
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: how do i'm
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so
Caption: right
Caption: [Music]
Caption: foreign
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: um
Caption: what mark where are you mark open you
Caption: turn your camera on
Caption: um
Caption: okay you can you can see me yeah
Caption: yeah yeah we can see you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: hey friends i'm scott hanselman and i
Caption: was told to give you a tour of my office
Caption: this is nerds nerding what we're doing
Caption: is we're talking to people all over the
Caption: world because we're stuck in our houses
Caption: like my dream come true i've always
Caption: wanted to join scott held someone's
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what do you want
Caption: bye
Caption: [Music]
Caption: we got a little problem
Caption: as you know our motto is you need a
Caption: professional bodyguard delivered to your
Caption: door in less than half an hour you've
Caption: got it buddy but without an app ain't no
Caption: bodyguard getting delivered nowhere so
Caption: where are we with that uh the app is
Caption: almost ready uh we just need
Caption: three
Caption: more days we need it asap
Caption: okay team what's the status on the app
Caption: we're good to go except our login
Caption: experience is a disaster
Caption: we need something to keep our users data
Caption: private
Caption: and to keep the hackers out
Caption: and it needs to work flawlessly because
Caption: because i don't want to lose one single
Caption: customer i hear you so let's use off
Caption: zero off what now off zero it's an
Caption: identity platform fast easy logins just
Caption: what the boss wants can we make our own
Caption: authentication service come on the
Caption: ultimate key master you know we don't
Caption: have that kind of time we need to
Caption: confirm identities with passwords
Caption: fingerprint scans whatever the users
Caption: like to use observer can do that yeah
Caption: but it needs to be secure we can't have
Caption: our app compromised by breaches not a
Caption: problem and it needs to scale if we get
Caption: hit with a ton of traffic and if it
Caption: stalls or freezes up i will get fired we
Caption: can do this
Caption: [Music]
Caption: could you guys stop